whoo come on let's go boom and we're
live David Goggins your book is [ __ ]
fantastic man this has been my running
partner the audio version of it has been
my running partner for the last week
it's [ __ ] amazing man well I
appreciate that thank you well you guys
are doing something about very unusual
the book is great I've read I've read it
like sat down read read but the the
audiobook is really interesting right
because you and the gentleman he wrote
it with Leah Adam Adam let's go Nick
Adams call Nick who reads it then you
come on and talk about things in between
so it's more than just the book rights
the book plus is the book plus like a
podcast right yeah so how that came to
be man as um as I was going through this
book for last year we would go through
change stuff up have so many stories man
we went through interview so many people
so many stories he would come back and
read it to me all my changes and when he
read it like man this guy has a great
reading voice I love his reading voice
and I started getting these different
ideas about doing it like you know what
maybe he can read and I can do my
podcast thing I'm aside and he can like
after he's chapter in between chapters
make it really interactive type of thing
and that's kind of how it came to be man
at the beginning I gotta be honest the
beginning I was like who is this
[ __ ] talking for David Gardens I
think you redo this why don't you do it
why are you but but it works right it
really does work yeah like as as it goes
on and I got also it's very obviously
you and him are good friends so when you
guys are talking then I don't mind him
reading for you as much for some strange
reason right I know it doesn't make any
sense
well I wouldn't say we're good friends
I'm just joking Adam looking here right
now he became a pain in my [ __ ] ass
during this process man because you know
he's just he's a real anal guy you know
he he helped out a lot you know I'm uh
I'm a real raw sadistic type of mindset
and he helped me put that on paper man
so I gave him a lot of credit for that
well it it comes across the book is
outstanding and you know it's it's it's
more than just sitting with like sitting
across you and you telling your story is
one thing
but this long detailed history of how
you became to be the person you became I
think it's very educational for people
because they can realize like oh he
wasn't always this guy right this is
what's [ __ ] up about people like you
see a guy who's like you who once I mean
how many ultra marathons did you run in
a row you were got some same as I ran
808 weekends in a row to stop and think
about that ladies and gentlemen 800s
means eight 100-mile races eight
weekends in a row a 100-mile race will
put you out for [ __ ] six months right
you know and you ran eight of them eight
weekends oh it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
insane accomplishment it was nuts you
think about a person like that you think
of them as in this like static fully
formed version right you don't usually
get to see and especially someone like
you who you went into so much depth
about your rise and fall and rise and
fall it wasn't like a straight linear
process between you getting inspired and
you becoming this bad [ __ ] no it
wasn't like what's that show called but
that Will Smith plays that that black
guy who kind of makes it in in the
financial world Pursuit of Happyness
I never saw that yeah it's a great movie
it wouldn't like pursue happiness man
like like with a guy struggles and he he
gets over it and he makes it yeah I fell
on my ass I thought got the top of Mount
Everest and my neighbors just [ __ ]
slide right underneath me I was like god
I start from scratch again scratch
became my friend literally man so you
know that's that's how you put in the
book man going up going down going up
just a real raw version of how my life
was in it was so in-depth to go back
through your life with a fine-tooth comb
that I almost got embarrassed even put
it out there to people yeah that's one
understand man like even me right now to
talk to you I'm in the car for a [ __ ]
hour getting pumped up cuz I'm a shy
introverted leave me a long time a guy
like I'm still that [ __ ]
who is six years old you know at a play
who can't say his line because I'm no
longer stood in front of five people so
I walk offstage that still me so every
day I'm fighting that do so people think
oh my god man you're a podcast look so
crazy so evil
no I'm trying to be locked in the Joe so
my mind isn't veer off saying let's run
out the damn door because people are
watching me on the [ __ ] podcast I
want to open it damn doing get out of
here man
so that's two real me so I'm not
sadistic man I'm focused don't we have
to do the stay locked into the game of
life and that's where and that's why I
tell people man I I go there I go there
that's one of the reasons why this book
is so good is because you're so honest
about your vulnerabilities and how you
overcome them and for people that see
someone who's a beast who's done great
things you just assume that they're
different than you right but then you
hear about your insecurities and your
pitfalls and all the things that went
wrong with you and you realize what
goddammit those the same things that go
wrong with me like maybe I have that
inside of me and I've just never
summoned it right and I'll tell you this
I start really realizing that when I
started overcoming myself I started
getting around these real alpha males
these hard hard men and I always put
people way above me I was growing up
like my god they had to have a lot more
than me to get to where they're at and a
lot of them did but once you get around
the the best of the best of the best
people you can kind of start breaking
them down and realizing man you you're
just as [ __ ] up as me like we all have
but all you did was you hit it better
your your your upbringing your mom and
dad your society the way you were raised
it hit it better than then did mine you
weren't the only black kid or there was
like five in a school you know I can't
hide going through buds I was only black
you can't hide but I started realizing
just because I look different than you a
lot of you my first kin hotter so I
started giving me courage through
watching people that were all have a
story we all have a jacked up life in
one way or another some of us don't have
the guts to talk about it though
and that's where I found the guts to
talk about mine well there's some is
purity in physical pursuits right
because it doesn't matter what your
social status is it doesn't matter how
people perceive you when it when it
comes down to how long can you stay in
that pool when it comes down to how far
can you run when it comes down to how
much can you push yourself past the part
where you want to quit how far can you
keep going there's a purity in that that
did dissolve social order all that
[ __ ] all the what people think about
you goes out the window it's what who
are you right now that's right who are
you right now that's a true statement
man and I look at this as a
psychological warfare and that's where I
started learning that that life is one
big psychological warfare that you play
on yourself
you clown yourself man the most
important conversation ever had myself
with myself and that [ __ ] I'll tell
myself was so [ __ ] up it was so wrong
it was so misguided and other people
start to write that dialogue for you
also and start to be what you said
yourself every single day and I started
creating a whole nother warfare a whole
nother battle started becoming I was
like oh hang on a second godness you
have these tools you have these tools
your life was basically the perfect the
perfect grounds for training for where
you need to go in your life all the
beatings are the other bullying all that
you know you going through learning
disabilities all the struggles it was
the absolute perfect training ground for
you to go to we need to go and that's
how I started looking at my life versus
what was me poopypants kick a rock down
the street mentality it was not God just
hooked you right to [ __ ] up he hooked
you right up man with the perfect place
you were training for the first 18 19 26
you were training for this stuff man you
have the advantage of everybody else
versus my god they're so above me they
came from a great family
mom and dad loved them they didn't have
learned that they started leading
struggle nah man your struggle is what
made you who you are now
so I started flipping this into a whole
different I started being a master of
what I was scared of I was get up my
mind and I became a literally a master
of that mind and that's what now from
now on it sets me apart from most people
I started diving into that well that is
a big part of the stories when you go
over your childhood and you know
your abusive father and then having this
great guy that was gonna become your
step down and then he gets murdered it's
like right when you're about to get out
of it
everything looks good boom and then he
gets murdered it's like these things
really did sort of set you up to start
from scratch again and just go okay
Roger that we start from scratch and now
you have that attitude you developed it
through all of these horrible personal
experiences all the trials and
tribulations all the evil [ __ ] that
people try to do to you that sort of set
you up to be able to deal in a way that
a lot of people can't well I used to
look at my life from a different vantage
point and when you're when you're in all
the muck and you're just walking in muck
and walking in muck and walk in the muck
you don't see that if you look off to
the [ __ ] left of the muck there's a
sidewalk brother get off get off of it
you you have your head down looking in
this muck once I saw the sidewalk got
the sidewalk I got a little break and I
got a different vantage point and then
from the sidewalk
I found a cliff and I found a mountain I
got way up high on top of my life and
look back down on it and said okay I
gotta figure this out man I'm not going
anywhere I'm trying to lie I'm started
like so we have a messed up foundation I
started up lying about everything I
wanted people to like me I wanted to be
accepted in some Society of life some
social Society and I say man this isn't
the right way I messed up here I messed
up here I messed up everywhere and so I
realized the worst thing that happened
to me is I lost myself I never had
myself never found myself I had no
self-esteem so I knew through working
out and through learning God it took a
lot for me to learn also I started
finding self-esteem once I found that
that's when doors start hoping I started
I stopped caring about people that what
they thought being judged well if I say
this if I started right now are you
making fun of me I stopped caring about
that and that's my life started really
changing for me
slowly but surely that that's such an
important point we were talking about
the working out because a lot of people
in they think about working out they
think of it as being a physical thing
right no no I did it for mental yeah
people are say my god like no don't
don't look at it like I didn't care
about losing weight I don't care about
being the fastest person I came out I
wasn't making the Olympics I won't go on
the pros
I could barely read and write when I was
in a junior in high school I wasn't
going anywhere
I saw working out as a way for me to
build calluses on my mind I had to
callus over the victims mentality so I
watched these movies I know I talked
about rocket last time I was on here
I always equated training to mental
toughening like it wasn't brutal people
waking up early and doing all these
things and look it looks horrible I was
like wow I got started doing that not to
get better bigger and stronger but that
is what's gonna build me that looks
uncomfortable that looks brutal and
getting up early I don't want to do that
some of this long list of things I don't
want to do and through that I found
myself I started like I'm like you guys
aren't doing this [ __ ] in high school
you guys are getting up at 5 o'clock in
the morning running over here in this
golf course so I started seeing myself
very differently than the average human
being I was like hang on a second I have
something they don't have and that's not
starts to develop these things do
working out it was this great
never-ending work ethic and through work
ethic I develop self-esteem now is this
something that you learn is this
something you learn yourself from from
exercise yourself or is it something you
had read or heard about like what made
you equate this doing this and doing
these difficult things physically to
mental toughness to being this is the
discipline that you need in order to get
your life out of the situation you're in
so I never read anything you know I
could barely read you know so I wasn't
reading back then I just saw I watched a
lot of movies and I was really big into
visualization and I always equated
working out to struggle and I struggled
my whole life but I ran from it so I
started realizing I got started facing
the struggle and I got be mentally
strong for the struggle so that's why I
started coming up like I'm training for
life mentally I'm training for life I'm
not training for like set to lift 400
pounds and I found out on my own pretty
much is that through this through
through discipline through
self-discipline through repetition do
tons of repetition the same thing that
you don't want to do that's it that's
the key thing do repetition the things
you don't want to do you develop mental
like
like an armor for your mind start to
armor your mind come on say okay we
suffer we suffer everyday that's what we
do we do stuff that sucks every day so
then when the suck stuff comes you're
ready for it and that's all started
coming up you know I just start being
very uncomfortable now I'm just like
just a way of life it's a crazy thing to
figure out though it's like that you
figured it out and you didn't just
figured out you embraced it like when
you were talking about your senior of
high school when you're talking about
your your mirror being your
accountability mirror like you had a
radical shift like you just decided to
not be a [ __ ] loser right and to
start tightening up and start holding
yourself accountable and and get ready
for things so I have this my whole life
and I mean I don't know if people
believe in God or what I don't care what
you believe in
there's been this unrelenting voice in
my head we all have this voice it's too
right or wrong voice and a lot of times
that voice guys instant to comfort and
my boys got it mean to comfort a lot but
I have this other voice I heard my whole
life say hey [ __ ] what are you
doing nah man we got to go over here we
had to go over here to that rock pile
over in the [ __ ] corner where
nobody's at that's that's where
victories at we're over in a corner so
this voice was giving me all these
answers not I went real smart kid
growing up but I had this crazy voice in
my head saying over there is where the
[ __ ] answers are and I won't listen
to it cuz over there was pain over there
was me looking in the mirror over there
was me being accountable for all these
things I went through my life you know
people put him on me it's now mine to
own and I'm gonna go over there by
myself but I had to and this voice was
guiding me there it's God would everyone
call it but that's what that's what it
wasn't me do you think that's just what
you when you separate yourself from your
ego and what you were your insecurities
and all you like if you were giving
yourself advice you would say that's
what the thing is to do so do you think
that's what it was like your
subconscious or though you stripped away
from all the [ __ ] when you couldn't
lie to yourself because it's a voice in
your head it's exactly it it's exactly
it cuz it knew it knew I was a character
I was trying to find myself through a
character I was making different
hairstyles and sagging my pants and I
was off I was off man I was
I was a clown I was a clown and I was
like this is not this is not what you're
supposed to be in life man and it's ugly
when you look in that dirty mirror and
you're trying to do a new hairstyle to
go to school you know I had the
hairstyle one time where I shaved the
top of my head you know how old men had
the hair like leaving their head yeah
yeah so I went to school with hair on
the side of my head and in my back and I
shaved the whole top of my head I just I
went to school like that you know and
then I hit like what did the kids say I
wasn't
I don't remember they said but it was I
was just a funny dude you know so that
was my thing I was the funny dude that
came into school like criss cross came
out when I was in high school so my
pants were backwards I see no I have my
pants backwards sag down past my ass
crack shirt turn backwards with a
toothbrush in my mouth with the reverse
part reverse party as your head is
shaved and you have some hair on top
just a little piece of hair versus like
a like a part right new hair the part
was on a bald head so it was just I I
would sit at home instead of studying I
would think about what can I do to
impress the [ __ ] at school and
that became my life and that is it's a
long road to hoe to get to the guy who
says now you don't ever smile on any
podcast looks so serious
I look at that [ __ ] like you
[ __ ] have no idea who I am who
I've come from to get here today you
could have probably been an entertainer
like you probably because you were doing
all that kind of [ __ ] have some jokes
Joe I got some jokes yeah you do so what
people read in this book can't hurt me
it's a sad story it's a horrible story
it's a tragic story it's a story that
made me who I am today
but you have to learn to laugh at
yourself too once you once you go
through that [ __ ] I now so there's a lot
of parts in there was like me against a
lot of white people you know and I have
a routine that I won't do so people who
hire me to speak I'm not going to do the
routine I often do it sometimes I think
about it I was a 36 black guy to go
through still training okay it's not how
many people out of probably looking at
probably 11 12 to make it through
probably 13,000 seals I was probably the
36 of the 36
I gotta make it through and over just
like they liked in 1940 you know you're
looking at almost 70 years Wow
yeah so you know you know you know do
the math on that so there's not a lot of
black guys and so I take that and I make
a nice comedy skit out of that [ __ ] you
know like like like the first time they
tied me up and threw me it's called
drown proofing yeah
so I'm negative boring as hell you know
me too well related to that big-time yes
you want a few white boys man they're
they're negative boy and that's hard
so imagine them getting your hands and
feet tying your ass up and throwing the
[ __ ] waters they swim ah it was like
throwing a cat in the water with [ __ ]
a brick on him
so I was just losing my [ __ ] mind so
is so many things had to get over you
know and I found humor I found humor in
my suffering I was like [ __ ]
what are you doing out here Gaga it's
like this is crazy like you're you're
literally trying to reinvent the wheel I
was trying to reinvent my mind I was
trying to reinvent my mind and I used
every single tactic possible to do that
I didn't want to live you know live in
this world where I was a fake human
being anymore and I was tired of blaming
everybody for all that my dad beat me
this happened I mean my dad ran
prostitutes man my dad literally
snatched the soul out of my mom like my
mom is still battling like that's my mom
left my dad and this one I'll talk about
in the book she got married three times
for a total of six months you know I'll
go there and I'm not gonna talk about
the guy she married so this woman was
she's beautiful she's she's so smart all
this stuff man this guy literally
stripped her soul away tonight and I
said you don't keep watching it and I
had no sort of begin with him I and my
brother he has a story that he could
write eight books you know my dad this
came through this wash this all clean so
to to to come still around he died about
four years ago four or five years ago
not for sure I didn't go to the funeral
but I forgave them so I saw my dad
through an eight-year-olds eye so it was
always left when I was eight and then
that 22 I went back just seeing through
a grown man's eyes and he's the same
person I remembered but I had to you
can't live with hate you cannot move
forward as much as that guy try to ruin
all of her lives that's where I came
from I had to figure out the origin of
where I started from
so when I was going back to
life trying to fix Who I am the [ __ ]
that person I was like if your knee
hurts is usually not your [ __ ] knee
that's hurting there's something else
man like it could be a tight quad it
could be the right leg if it's the left
leg you gotta find out the origin of
where all this [ __ ] began and it was him
so I had to go back to where you know my
roots and the origin of all this
happened and it's hard to do that did
you make peace with them I'm a big piece
with so we didn't have a peaceful
conversation we you know we left very
garanimal he's a he's a he's a vicious
man he was a vicious man
I mean medieval [ __ ] so I had
become a medieval [ __ ] that time
I was 22 and I was the big boy and so I
was no longer the guy who was afraid it
was not like hey I want to kill you type
of [ __ ] and we were sitting at Denny's
after an all-night skate or whatever the
hell no he owned bars and skating rinks
like that and so we were sitting down
and we kind of got into it and I was
kind of left and but I had to make peace
with it in myself like I could not hold
on to that hate cuz hold on to that hate
was half the reason why I kept falling
into the same pattern of failing I had
to get I start dumping off some baggage
I had to start figuring out me through
him and that's all he was there for he
was the origin
I had to figure him out figure out why
he was so evil to my mom to me my
brother and I to start studying him like
a lot of people have situations where
someone does something and we all
attacked that person like like on the
media if someone does something wrong
everybody now is [ __ ] perfect
and we now judge this guy I don't judge
him I don't judge anybody what I do is I
start studying them why did they do that
not in a judging way I want to learn
from you and what you get out of your
dad I got that he was he grew up rough
he had he was very insecure had a lot of
kids and his insecurities just trickled
over onto us so yeah he jacked us up
real good but he never fixed himself so
if you never fix yourself the next
person in line is gonna get the wrath
and we were next in line you know his
his first wife you know killed herself
or whatever happened and you know got
burnt up in the house or something some
craziness and his life stuff that goes
on there that
putting a book is I don't like going to
court you know but uh yeah that's all it
was law stuff you know one of the great
parts about this book is that you you
detail exactly what was going to your
mind in terms of like your weaknesses
and how you had failed and and then you
it's not just one time like you you do
the thing in high school
where you get your [ __ ] together and
then you join the military and then you
wind up getting fat again and then when
you got you and you have to lose what
106 pounds in three months up to to
qualify for seal try SEAL training yep
that's insane yeah because what I
realized at that time once again I
failed again I thought so what you're
talking about is I took this as map test
you know I didn't know how to read him
right pretty much in high school I was
like a fourth grade reading level and I
took that test a few times and I finally
passed it and when I passed it I
actually drove my car to the to the
daggone airport and watched planes take
off because I was like I'ma be on one of
those planes one day going to Air Force
bootcamp so I I never I always fixed the
things on the surface so if I couldn't
read him right and learn to read him
right I I would always fix these things
on the surface level and so whenever
something hard was like raising ugly
head I didn't have any kind of tools to
handle it all right man i thought i
fixed this already man but nah i didn't
go deep into the dungeon of my soul and
say okay what is making you a quitter
what is making you a weak man what is
making you afraid and so that's why I
kept on quitting and going back to start
or not knowing how to get through hard
times and that's why I was telling
people I'm not a theorist I didn't study
like you know I didn't study a [ __ ]
book I literally put myself in a fire
repeatedly like a sword you put a sword
in a fire repeatedly repeatedly if you
keep on doing that you're gonna get a
nice sword and then keep on beating it
you got to beat the [ __ ] out of it
and that's what I am yeah I I became
that much I said okay we can't quit we
got to figure out why you are this [ __ ]
why are you this [ __ ] man what is wrong
with you what's going on here
so I kept on putting the sword back in
the daggone fire and I just beat it
harder and I beat it harder before I
knew I start realizing hmm all right
ma'am the brain is starting to get hard
the brain is starting to get hard I'm no
longer a theorist I'm now a practitioner
I put it in hell I dissected it while
it's in hell can you can't dissect
anything in a normal environment
you can't dissect anything in 72 degree
weather you must put it in the [ __ ]
freezer and freeze the [ __ ] out of it
and then you dissect it dissect it when
it's miserable dissect the brain when
all this thinking about I need to get
out of here man I want to get out of the
[ __ ] freezer open the door and he
said nah five more seconds man five more
seconds in the freezer and a sneeze
tried to pick that brain apart and
that's what all this stuff did to me I
kept on putting myself back into the
freezer or the fire and beating the [ __ ]
out of myself mentally and physically
before I knew it this is what happened
Wow it's an interesting way to self
teach yes like most people that you know
you talk to that a discipline they you
know they have something that they read
that inspired them they have certain
people that they look up to there's
certain you know coaches that taught
them there's certain important moments
in their life but for you it's a system
of failure and and reflection and then
rebooting that's it repeat it failure
and people think a lot of times to tell
me that I'm angry oh my god you so angry
you cuss so much oh my god so much are
you still crazy if you read my book I
cannot explain my life by saying hey it
was a merry [ __ ] Christmas man no it
wasn't I want you I want you to go there
with me I'm taking you there with me I'm
a storyteller I want to take your ass
down paradise where I sold the house I
lived in in Buffalo New York I got my
ass beat every day funny we lived on
Paradise Road and there was anything but
[ __ ] paradise so I want you to go
there with me you want to learn from me
let me take your ass home
take you there so that's the whole thing
about it man we're scared to dive into
our lives what made us who we are the
beautiful people that we are we're all
jacked up in so many ways that's the
beauty of us that's the beauty of me I'm
jacked up but I figured out my own
little process on how to get on jacked
up and how did I'm not gonna get the
same you know I'm not gonna get the same
way you're gonna get there you may get
there about going point A to point B I'm
gonna go point C to D to eat it I don't
to be there the same way you are just a
little harder that's how I train my
brain so it's just different different
different thinker when you stop and
think about all the different times that
you did have to reboot and how you you
found like new goals and you found new
inspiration you fired up a new
discipline and you became stronger and
harder and you got one of the things
that people always look for in life they
look for a point where they can rest
[Laughter]
they loved that expression the Golden
Arrows they loved that expression yeah
they loved the they loved the idea of a
struggle as long as it ends and then
when it ends they're gonna have a nice
comfortable spot it must yeah
the suffering must end yeah you should
relax man you've done so much that's
right you've really done so much but
this the idea of reaching this golden
year is is it's a very flawed idea
because it's an idea that you're gonna
you're gonna work hard but then you're
gonna reach the finish line but there's
no finish line no doesn't exist that's
the scary thing about life my friend
that is a scary thing right and that's
what fatigues me people though man why
don't you ever smile
there's no [ __ ] in my friend there's
no end I know that you're you're you're
going to meet campaigns after this yes
sir and listen please if you guys run
put a number of that miles that you're
going to run and leave it at that do not
say let's see you both die cuz that's a
hard man he is a hard man when Haynes is
a hard man he will run until you die or
he dies he's a hard man do
he doesn't he does those two 40s yes
ultra he's a sick [ __ ] see those are the
guys I'm looking for yeah that's a scary
do you don't do too you guys you need to
pick a number I know I think you guys
gonna run 35 miles good texting back and
forth try and make it you know trying to
make it sensible oh yeah so we don't go
off the chain cuz if one of you
[ __ ] wakes up and has a good
strong espresso I know you know this new
race that they're doing where they're
you run for one hour you run like as
many and then you have like a bell rings
and then you sit down for a little bit
you know what I mean like you there's
like a four point one seven mile thing
yep it's that sick [ __ ] what was the
guy's name that created that like I did
the Berkeley marathon yes he talked
about last yeah this crazy [ __ ] laughs
so he had people running for days and
days and days he invited me out there
for this race yeah I actually got into
the Berkeley last year but couldn't do
it because the book so I'm supposed to
do it this year but now you know we'll
see you again how the schedule goes but
yeah that that's a sick sick man I've
done a couple of his races like he has
one called strolling Jim I actually won
that one in 2016 but he's a he's a sick
man as a straw throwing Jim race it is
probably easiest race it's like it's
like through the backcountry of
Tennessee it's a forty one mile race on
the road it's one the first you know
ultra marathons out there ever and my
mom lives in Nashville so is like an
hour drive I went up there and it was
like my first race is back after me
being all sick and jacked up for so long
and I got lucky had a good race and I
happen to want it you know you were
talking about so ice muscle yeah and all
that we have this thing now that we've
got that what does that call the pro so
right so right if you ever used what
happened awesome I saw it in there that
that little black contraption that hard
plastic thing is phenomenal it's evil
man yeah yeah it's good amazing I
started getting tightness in that when I
was running a lot like I had never
gotten tightness in that area before yes
it seems like that's a running thing
right is there anything also a very
stressed thing
mmm you know if you're real stressed out
man like for me I talked about the
origin like I'm where things start my
body was so wrapped tight I didn't know
where
we're start yeah so I started with the
psoas muscle so that's a real good spot
well the problem with these races is
probably the problem with people like
you that's the problem with these races
like if you get you and another you
right and they're in there together like
you [ __ ] are gonna kill each
other so long day it's a long day
they're doing a Last Man Standing right
yeah like the first person to quit yeah
it's a real long day man I mean I've
been up I got a couple of Hillary's
under my belt me I know how to sail 430
hours and move yeah and I know how to
self motivate a lot of [ __ ] are
self motivate man like we like to put
the headphones on yeah like before the
big game and listen to the music yeah
what the [ __ ] did you do when the
headphones come off bro it's you and
your own mind right I know how to do
that that's that's the hard part
remember listen to music when you run
never never told you James cheat is that
video I got well I talked about like
running with music and no what did you
say I find it find the video will play
it I might not be able play it we get
this is somebody else's content I
actually uh but I did during my last
pull up record I listened to you know
that song from Rocky one around 14 when
rocky gets knocked down the corner I
listened to that two minutes and 13
seconds long
listen I'll repeat for 17 hours Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas man 17 hours
man I went to such the dark dark evil I
have a picture in my hand the book I was
in a dark I went to I went to a place
man that I'm like I can do anything here
we got a live here for a while oh can I
keep on filling that record like I don't
want to see a pull-up bar again I mean
like I did 67,000 Pulis man and I just
admire I like I can't I don't wanna see
no pull-up so I'm doing this come hell
or high water man I I broke it out it's
just a bit let me hear this let me this
place
so I've never trained with music there's
a reason why I'll do that
the music's not going to always be there
the TV the distractions all these
external things I'm gonna gym right now
and all this loud music people needed to
get fired up they needed to stay
motivated
the [ __ ] stay in the fight they get
into this goal in the gym to do whatever
trying to do what do you do they have no
external motivation turtle who say to
yourself
how you gonna fire yourself up what's
that flame inside of you that keeps you
going like that keep going like this
and when you're doing this the whole
time you're doing this you're doing some
of the hardest chin-ups you can do you
got a chain around your neck right the
post folks that are just listening and
you're pulling down on ropes you're
doing chin-ups on it looks like taped up
ropes
yes sir that's what it is yeah those are
grip yeah that's like jiu-jitsu guys do
a lot of those yes I was I spoke to the
University of Alabama and they were in
there you know most you know most these
athletes man they got to get height so
that music is blaring yeah I'm like man
what that [ __ ] comes off and you get
popped in your [ __ ] mouth yeah
headphones on the sidelines brother yeah
we can say to yourself then so that's
that's how I train my mind man I train
my mic I'm no one get popped in my mouth
man I'm gonna get popped in the back of
an alley one day a man running around
doing what I do and there's to be no
music ya better fight you never figured
out I told you Jamie's cheating I was
telling when I first started running
people said do you run with music
there's no run-ins cheating when you
have music on it's cheating you're
cheating you listen to music but now I
listen to music all the time but more
than I listen to music I listen to books
yeah what books on tape audiobooks and
yours is like I said it's been the last
two weeks it's been my running partner I
appreciate that man
just supporting the nominal man that's
phenomenal and you're doing this kind of
independently right yeah so what I did
man is I pissed off a lot of people I
was I so in 2012 I got an offer from my
book for $30,000 I said you can go [ __ ]
yourself you know what he'll I went
through brother so then everybody was
like you know we don't see a market for
a black guy ultrarunner fat guy who
couldn't read like you know 15 percent
of America's black you know I want to
see me [ __ ] you know people will buy
on your book they think only black
people will buy your book there's some
ignorant people out there man everybody
that follows me is white I don't have a
bug
like three black for hoseman event was
just Larry's the big fatties black yeah
he's like he's like an unusual species
outside man like and so I'm sitting
walking around going man you don't even
know who like everybody talked to is
white like you know it's the ignorance
of the world and I'm in these meetings
hearing this kind of stuff so now 2018 I
get a $300,000 offer for a first time
author
so I'm sitting back you know I'm like my
god man you know I used to make like
[ __ ] $60,000 a year you know this is
the biggest payday yet and I started
thinking I took that one sec I talked
about the one second decision a lot
about what I went through my life what
I've done and I was like you know what I
struggled so hard in my life I went
through so much that the biggest trophy
I own now is that book the biggest
trophy I don't know it's not the book is
selfish what's in the book mmm it's what
like I don't give a [ __ ] if that sells
my copy
honest to god man like like my what I
did and that's what I hope people
understand your life in the journey you
put yourself through there's no there's
there's nothing more than that and
that's all I want people to do is
realize that you have to struggle you
have to struggle the bigger the struggle
the bigger the piece the bigger the
suffering the more piece I'm not just
saying this cuz you here but this book
is valuable this book is very valuable
it's valuable to people like anybody
that you know I mean the biographies are
very always valuable when you get to see
the mindset of a person who's done
things that you haven't done you get to
understand like that they're overcoming
sort of the same sort of situations in
their mind that you are same
insecurities and pitfalls yeah
everybody's going through it man yeah
everybody that's that's one thing I say
I'm blessed that way that my story
there's no colour involved in it it's a
human story about struggle and I happen
to be in so many different situations
that so many people can relate to about
struggle that I guarantee you mark my
word you read that book there will be a
section of that book that resonated use
our core it will make you think if if
you're not ready to think about your
life and think about you know where you
can be and think about what you haven't
done the books not for you if you're not
ready to self notice you really self
reflect and hold yourself a
countable for where you're at and where
you're not the book is not for you is
real I've read a lot of self-help books
and I've listened to a lot of self-help
books on tape too and a lot of just some
of them that I have to shut off I have
to shut off a quarter way and I feel
like someone's lying to me I just like
you're bullshitting me you're just
saying things I'm not this doesn't
resonate with me doesn't it's not
working like I'll give it a chance I'll
give it a chance but if I'm you know
half hour in two hours in it's still the
same nonsense I don't feel anything
right gettin itchy listening to you you
know I just want to pull the headphones
off and I'll just kill it stop it this
is the total opposite this one man I was
I was good I was running extra mile so I
could stay with the headphones on and
the the thing that I think is gonna
happen with this book is people gonna
get it they're gonna get a hold of
whether it's an audio book or the or the
book book and they're gonna they're
gonna recommend it and then it's gonna
spread like wildfire this is a powerful
book this is a real self-help book this
is like this is a real one like it's not
like someone orchestrates this whole
thing like what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna become a motivator right I'm gonna
be a personal influencer I'm gonna be
that guy that goes out there and tells
people you can optimize your life and
there's so many of those [ __ ] guys
out there right yeah That's not me
I know this one dude I ran into him
recently I ran into him with this
restaurant he's fat as [ __ ] he's got
this big old belly and I know he does
these these motivational things and I'm
looking at him like what are you talking
about man right weak right look at your
body look at your own temple look at
your meat vehicle you're riding around
this [ __ ] doughnut around your waist
is just he was a funny look soft and
like wake up [ __ ] so many people are
doing that now man people are talking
this noise exactly and I see him yeah I
know him
I'm not gonna say names but I know I'm
like man dude you know why my life is
miserable right now because I can't go
on your show right now your podcast if I
didn't get after this morning so I
cannot talk to people unless you're thin
unless I'm authentic cuz I used to be
the most unauthentic [ __ ] on the
planet now I have this voice man saying
oh no I'll call you well if I lie to you
about something even a white lie
hey yo Joe guess what dude
I [ __ ] lie female like that wasn't
real like it will bother me that
background you know so another thing I
didn't which funny ball this book stuff
man I didn't set out to write a book
like literally man when I was 24 years
old on accounts fat's praying for
cockroaches eating doughnuts and
drinking milkshakes I did not plan on
doing this all I wanted to do was change
the [ __ ] reflection in that daggone
mirror this is all this to Bob it's it's
it's a byproduct of of that and that's
that's the funny thing about like it was
like oh my god David Gaga's but you know
what tell you I'm like what the [ __ ]
that's why it works though unbelievable
it works because you really did do it
you really did do all those things and
you show how you did it and you're not
using any [ __ ] theatrical jargon no
you're not you know you're you know
you're not saying a bunch of buzzwords
can you live the life of an actualized
person I can show you how and you look
in this guy talking he's gonna neck like
a pencil and is his body's just frail I
don't even understand adversity you
don't understand overcoming this is not
the secret you know is it about the law
of [ __ ] attraction yeah they say no
attraction here brother
this ain't no attraction to your man
yeah I love nonsense this is no nonsense
no nonsense this is a real self-help
book man this is the real deal that's
how you self-help you self-help by
people have done it and you learn what
they did and you realize there's no
shortcuts right and then you learn to
embrace that no shortcut mentality and
enjoy enjoy the suffering and the grind
of n what we talked about earlier
there's no [ __ ] finish line doesn't
exist you know what's funny about that
is I have people now so when I was in
the worst part of my life those people
want to bring you back in those people's
like like you can see who you hang out
with like when you and your worst and
when you trying to get better with what
makes it hard to get better is that you
are hanging around people who I let's
say you are an alcoholic you hang around
people who drink and I say you want to
stop drinking those people want to bring
you back in like I used to be this guy
this guy who was know who wasn't worth
anything now those people who are still
there they're sixteen seventeen eighteen
thirty years ago they try and get you
back there so the hardest part you guys
see who you hanging
with man you gotta hang out with the
people who you want to be like the most
yeah people will definitely drag you
know Jackie down and especially if you
around someone that makes a lot of
excuses and I was failing
oh those is just like there they're the
opposite of inspiration they're like a
vacuum sucking it out of you why are you
doing that today man why you get up
again so early why are you doing this
why are you doing this the people you
hang around it will suck the [ __ ]
life out of you
yeah sometimes just gotta be a long man
get your [ __ ] in and then there's also
people that are gonna be around that are
always failing and always [ __ ] up and
then always coming to you to try to get
you to help them exact um a giant burden
yes never look in the mirror and get
their own [ __ ] together those looking
for external health that's right
always looking for story people don't
want to go in deep man all the answers
are inside of you it's a very primitive
way how this book is written is
primitive it's this it's very barbarians
it's how we all think it's not it's how
a man once walked the earth and then we
get all soft and all these computers and
[ __ ] we say we start going away from the
most powerful thing we have is our
[ __ ] brain is our mind and we don't
use anymore so you know it's like
everything has to be so quick yeah you
use your mind when it comes to certain
things right but what you're saying is
you don't use your mind when it comes to
enduring exactly that is it
you can't Google that [ __ ] right hey let
me Google how to suffer hey Kobe in
there bro hey go be in there hey Kobe in
there it doesn't exhaust find some water
real cold and what's interesting is that
that is a mind thing and people think of
mind things they think of calculating
mathematics literature no no no there's
many aspects of them that's it
don't overthink it yeah no ever think it
put your shoes on lace them up it's how
you got to do my friend don't overthink
the process yeah but see what because
you've overcome and because you've
accomplished so much now that even when
you you talk about that moment of like
embracing that suck like you see the
biggest smile in your face like you've
you've got a total different approach to
it than the average
person oh yeah the average person you
talking to them about doing chin-ups for
24 hours or anything I'm [ __ ] crate
they don't look at it like oh there's
like a- a doom feel that's the thing
about it man I talk about my book
open-mindedness what separates me from a
lot of people is they go into an a
daunting task and the task is
overwhelming like when I heard the
pull-up rack was 4,000 and 20 pull-ups
not talking about breaking this record
people are like oh my god I went right
to a pen and paper thing what are you
doing I'm doing the math man every Tompa
I'm open mind to the fact that okay if I
do 5 pull-ups in a minute for some of
you hours I can get something pull-ups
in how much time that the rest I was
breaking the math down you have to be
open-minded to the possibilities that I
can do this once you shut your mind down
to the possibility that it can be a
cheese is no way it can happen so that's
why my my eyes and my body light up
about things because I know that if
you're in a fight you have to attack you
have to keep attacking the enemy has to
know he is not going to give up you must
break the soul of whatever the [ __ ] is
in front of you that's what I realized
I was never breaking the soul of
anything in front of me so that's why I
came with the thing called taking souls
in my book I started to devise ways to
break a soul of a human being of an
object of whatever's in front of me if
you keep on attacking something nothing
wants to stand in front of anything that
is relentless
nothing did taking soul part of the book
is really interesting because you talked
about like the the mind shift that you
had when you were in buds yes sir yeah
that was it that's an intense part of
the book yes it is a that's when a lot
of stuff started clicking man I start
watching those instructors on the side
because know there's there's three
shifts there's eight instructors three
shifts good you know the guy's going to
do hell week they're up all day and all
night 430 hours this is the promised
land of mental hardening for me I love
this place and you have the instructors
who know you know they've been there
done that now they're instructing you so
they do their eight-hour shift they have
their parkas on it's usually cold coffee
drinking their coffee and they're
beating the crap out of us and when I
start to realize I start playing mind
games like you know what
but these [ __ ] are looking at us
judging themselves about when they were
going through hell week about let me see
I'm looking at Goggins right now I was
better than him I was betting that cos
betting that [ __ ] over there and I was
like okay okay you got something to do
to you so what I started doing was I got
my beaucoup beaucoup - it's in the book
is a great great story said camera guys
you can't break boat crew - you can't
break bro crew - so Ria's Wednesday is
Wednesday never has broken ever has beat
up man in like this I mean you start
moon like a robot everybody's like just
kind of just trying to get through hell
week now and your Energy's at and they
know Wednesday's like that over the hump
a lovely you talked about that in the
book - that they put it in your head oh
yeah Wednesday you're gonna be tired
yeah and that's nothing they they tell
you how you're supposed to feel so you
are feeling that way
that's like ah don't let these
[ __ ] tell you how you supposed
to feel know it's day one [ __ ]
this is our one so I always get my boat
crew all jacked up I said we could take
these [ __ ] souls so when they
had us doing a simple thing that guys
are struggling with Roku 2 is just
washing the [ __ ] boat and you're
yelling yeah you can't [ __ ] hurt us
can't hurt boat crew - and I looked on
the instructors faces and it looked like
someone had just [ __ ] with their soul
and I looked at my guys in the book and
I said hey guess what those
[ __ ] aren't [ __ ] tonight can
we own space in their [ __ ] head
Rhian space they're gonna think about us
tonight they could think about how these
killing boners that's right
how on Wednesday are these guys doing
this and screaming out you can't hurt in
care - we were we were bringing the
fight we were attacking so when you keep
on doing that guess what people start
doing I ain't [ __ ] with these guys no
more so bro crew - got a lot more sleep
well crew - just became that beaucoup
like a because we just kept charging and
we started fueling off of that we
started feeling out the fact that man it
takes one second of energy to steal
everybody's and then you have all the
energy you need it's all you need you
need to look at someone's eyes you know
how this when you fight somebody you
broke that [ __ ] he's like oh god
man I don't want to go back to the next
round and you feel like my god I can
fight all day I can fight all
long that's what taking souls is but you
have to have the will to heart the
courage to go that distance when you're
exactly jacked up we have nothing left
to give and give more there's an
interesting thing about the mind is that
you can find inspiration and when you
find inspiration when you get charged up
all of a sudden you have energy that's
right it's right it's weird I talked
about in the book also is about I've
learned how to control my adrenals if
you know how you know how you get that
fight-or-flight response when you get to
move real quick yeah and you know I I
started learning the mind a lot how to
get myself jacked extremely fast like in
a horrible environment when everybody's
miserable I've learned how to really
find strength in the misery when
everybody's suffering everybody's all
poopy past and different counties down
and everything I started just like my
god this is where I shine I start using
all that misery for tons and tons of
tons of Drive and motivation to to then
lead people further because you can get
a lot of power through misery and once
people see that my godness is [ __ ]
going then everybody says Roger that let
me get my [ __ ] and go too so I started
realizing that if you can just find
strength just a little bit longer you
will have a crew of people following you
along the way and that is another thing
that no one can ever teach you this is
you you're gonna have to learn that on
your own you're gonna have to figure out
how to pull that energy out of your mind
on your own there's not there's there's
no book you can read that all sudden I
have it I've got the technique now I
know how to do it ya know it's it's a
grind that you have to start and finish
on your own you have to take great
pleasure in the fact that no one wants
to be with a [ __ ] you're at right now
great pleasure in that almost makes you
know it have to bring a passion idea has
to bring something very very weird out
of you man like you know people don't
really understand what that is when
you're in the worst environment possible
the worst situation possible and
everybody's looking like god I hope this
ends and you see that time slows down
and you see that you're you're feeling
that
everybody has that look on their face I
goddess gotta go I don't want to be any
more have you ever gotten robbed Oh
robbed on my lord oh yes sir did you get
it yes sir yes sir
when did you get I got it on my second
pull up record attempt and I talked
about it a little bit in the book there
and it max me I have sickle cell trait
and a young kid just died from rhabdo
from sickle cells not a good thing
obviously and grab grab those a bad
thing for having sickle cell you have
sickle cell trait but you derive the
disease I had the disease my buddy mine
died from it when I was a kid really
yeah I used to fight with I used to
train with yeah he was always sick he'd
have it to get sick
it's horrible be gone be out of the gym
for months and come back and just be
trying to get his body back in shape
again that gets ya anyone I'm dying he's
a talented guy too when you got it what
did you have to do so they put me in a
hospital for a while that's what my hand
got real messed up and my fluids were
extremely low and I had done like I did
3000 pull-ups and they're like man your
body is wrecked up we just not drinking
water while you're doing I was drinking
water but not enough so I was sipping
this carbohydrate drink mm-hmm and my
calories are extremely low I don't know
how much I was gonna burn through and
you burn through an awful lot of
calories man doing that when you pull up
to that many hours you know
and with the repetition with using the
single points of just my hands and my
biceps on my back like my body was
swollen like the Pillsbury Doughboy I
mean it looked horrible and I'm so they
kept me in there for awhile but how long
probably about eight hours
I was intubated hours and all the IVs
and stuff like that so they just
basically ignored of it you know tons of
fluid and they sent me home though so I
go home that night and how long did you
wait before you jump back at it I think
I was back on the pull-up bar about a
week and a half later and then I broke
the record six six weeks later I broke
the record Jesus Christ so when you when
you did get back on the pull-up bar it
was how [ __ ] up was your body from it
was bad but what I do is like I've done
through everything it was
real smart I mean it works for me so I'm
not saying do this is I've trained
through a lot of my injuries and I
started developing I started doing that
in butts and SIL training because I
still train you know they know you got
start from day one
or they just kick you out so I started
from day one enough so my third time
going through I was really jacked up but
you went you had pneumonia yeah I had
pneumonia and I had really bad stress
fractures so my stress fracture so I was
literally I would put a sock on and then
duct-taped my foot all the way up to the
top of my or to the min of my Inc or
attended my calf and cut my stress
fractures were so bad so at the pivot
point between my ankle in my shin I just
casted that all the way up and so I went
through for several months for a few
months with stress fractures what was
crazy about that is they healed by the
time I got the third phase my stress
fractures were healed Wow and I don't
even know how Rama reason behind it I
ran on him a few months later they were
healed Wow so I don't know what that is
push through the agony and eventually
your body just said this crazy [ __ ] is
not gonna stop its true statement yeah
it's weird a lot of my injuries I've
just pushed through and they've I duck
tape it up I hope you never have surgery
no just heart just a couple heart
surgeries but um none of my actual
physical body and what was your heart
surgery for again you talked about this
before yeah
ASD I had a whole new heart yeah so we
talk about more ridiculous yeah that's
what we talked about that too man they
uh they took me off and studied me for a
while so they realized that my god yeah
I shouldn't even be in the military I
wasn't qualified to be the military to
hole in the heart you know let alone be
in Special Operations we jump in our
planes and stuff like that so I was I
was lucky how'd they seal that up so
they winning with the helix patch and
you know through my femoral artery
femoral artery and they went through put
a patch and they realized you know I
missed like three or four years of a
military career because that's heart
surgery Wow
yeah so I was I was off of jump status
dive status I was just so that's what's
all about recruiting so much
I stayed in recruiting for like three or
four years and you know I became like if
Navy SEAL recruiter when I was uh you
know doing this for a while so I got
extended there because the heart surgery
and that
other than that you'd never had to have
any other surgeries um no meniscus no
nothing no that's crazy
no and I've had some jacked-up injuries
but see how I grew up you know like I
talk about in the book my dad and
believe in taking him by the hospital
like that's how it was man it was it was
barbarian stuff man
but you know you learn to deal with it
and you live it you're fine you get hard
MRIs oh yeah get nothing checked out
matter of fact me I was terrified MRI
machine for long time I lost focus like
man that's it
yeah there's a lot of this lot behind
that man but yeah I've been checked out
while I've had so like I said like six
years ago I started stressing out like I
was dying I couldn't even get a bed so
all that stretching that was from pretty
much all these injuries I had that I
never really fixed and my body got
knotted up and more knotted up and more
knotted up in me it's gonna heal one way
or another it's gonna heal and when it
heal it's not a hill right so heal all
jacked up and crooked yeah so I'm a
crooked jacked up dude man but I still
get it to her it's amazing that you
haven't had like knee surgeries or
anything like that consider all the
running and I've done my left knee right
now is in there's no joke so like I say
origin of pain my right foot is messed
up because my left knee so right now I'm
taking care of my left knees getting lot
better now but don't worry Cameron
Haines I got me [ __ ] out there
running with your ass I'm not gonna get
out of it buddy
so if you listenin [ __ ] I will
see you this weekend Merry Christmas all
right just so you know brother Merry
Christmas I'll see you soon you don't
know what's wrong with the knee you have
no idea
it's from stretching so basically
retching yeah so my whole cuz my body
was in such bad alignment from just what
I did to it mm-hmm
that now I'm on this huge stress routine
and my body's getting back into
alignment so your muscles like I was a
power lifter man like I I grew these
huge muscles now on this small guy and I
just and from the stress of my body
going through hell weeks and also my
body's got became one knot so as things
start to open up joints start to hurt
things start to hurt and I'm like God so
it's been this big long process so I'm
better safe than ever my organs work
better I'm healthier than ever but I
have these little tweaks here these
little tweaks they're from the fact that
I am now my body was locked into
position
mmm from these muscles being so tight
now what do you weigh now about 180 to
183 and you were like 300 plus pounds
for you got your father stir my fattest
we're not waiting it for the military I
don't know my fattest would but when I
weighed in I'm at scale when Steven Sal
hit that scale on me man I was 297 and
he's like brother you gotta lose a
hundred and six pounds I was like [ __ ]
this I can't are you talking about other
how's it possible so it just you know I
had a lot of time that's the crazy um
they didn't give you three months to
lose that 33 pounds a month is a lot of
[ __ ] weight plus a few and what's
impossible and that's what I thought
that's why I thought but see you see the
person him now yeah I was a hurtin 75
pounds in high school so I was I'm a
skinny guy in high school
so I made myself big I'm a small bone
person so it it wouldn't it trust me it
was hard it was hardest thing I've ever
done in my life but what did people
think around you when they saw you three
months later you're a hundred pounds
light and my mom couldn't believe it can
my mom so I was living in a puss in the
end of the time and so I was trying to
study for this ass bap test again that
you know I gotta take it again going in
the Navy and I'm out here trying to lose
weight and I'm you know working for this
company spraying for cockroaches and
also crap and I would lay in her pond in
[ __ ] November in Indiana just lay in
her pond I was like I'm going to bus I
get hard you know so I lay in the pond
gallop on and go for a run just all wet
cold like the daggone shirt with his
fries up from ice and [ __ ] and I see out
there run and said what is wrong with
you man like you were that kid who just
didn't want to push around with you so
she started seeing the transformation
like an you know this guy is obsessed
which I become somebody nestings new man
my god you actually lost that much
weight that fast I love the fact that
you did it but what what hurts me is
when I hear stories about people to get
like stomach stapling and surgery and
all that [ __ ] that they do like you just
need to just lose the weight alright and
if you just did it you just did it the
right way you would
earned it and if you earn it you'll keep
it that's the thing about it man like we
like to take these very quick fixes in
life we want the 6-minute ABS approach
to life you know nah man there's no
permanent in that yeah there's no
permanent in that man there's no
scarring
they must be scarring well people are
terrified of this thing that you're
saying that there's no end that there's
no finish line that every day is and the
thing that you have to earn it still
after all the [ __ ] you've done every day
you get up and you have to earn it
yes and it was funny about that I want
you to be scared of it yeah fuel it's
great motivation and see if you look at
that way the reason why I speak the way
I speak because I believe in long saying
if I ever shut it down that's the end of
me and whatever my hundred percent will
be I don't know this could happen to me
tomorrow if you can't run I will figure
what the [ __ ] I can do and do that that
would be my new hundred percent you must
continue to find your new 100 percent
whatever life throws at you you must
find what you can do now I may become
the best you know scientist of all time
who knows watch out you know saying who
knows well that is an approach like this
this approach this mental approach you
can use that for anything once you get
past the quitting mechanism of your mind
get past that thing that this is
applicable you can you can take these
lessons that you learn from these
grueling runs just losing 106 pounds in
three months from all these different
things of struggle you can take these
lessons of struggle and you can apply
them to anything yes I talk about it in
my book here about that race I did that
made SIL training look like a like a
child's play in range of school that the
first hundred mile or I did write [ __ ]
on myself and all kind of stuff that 19
hours it took me with no training
I summon up like this you're talking
about struggle how how you can put so
much of life into struggle in that 19
hours
I lived five years five years of
struggle of happiness of depression
success failure in
eighteen hours that's what's great about
some of these things I do you get a a
wide range of life in just 19 hours you
know like when you get to like mile 50
in your mind saying we gotta get out of
here man and you gets like mile CC okay
we're feeling good you have all these
highs and lows that you have to manage
within this suckfest of 19 hours and
that's what I get from a lot of these
different things that human growth you
know growth of the mind without friction
there is no growth without friction
there's no growth there's no growth and
there's no satisfaction mm-hmm like
there's no really like people want to
sit around and rest but you don't really
appreciate rest unless you earned it
that's it and people get they think I'm
the craziest person on the planet you
are so far [ __ ] removed from that
state was not even funny
I was 290 pounds twice in my life I do
not like to do the things I do but the
shoe mungus satisfaction from doing it
the shoe mungus aspects from lacing your
shoes up saying I don't really want to
go for a run today and then running and
then getting back and saying wow I did
it I did it yeah and that's what it's
about it's about these small steps to
doing things you don't want to do you
know Jocko chuckling I know him yeah
Jacko's don't know him great but I know
I know him pretty well he's awesome but
every morning you look at that
[ __ ] Instagram he's got a
picture of his watch at 4:30 he gets up
at 4:30 every morning and he earns his
sunrise ESCA still works out like a
[ __ ] and then earns a sunrise
that's good stuff
but it's that thing that there's no end
not as an end and scary scary scary
everybody wants that holding hands while
the Sun sets Oh
tire man you walk it off into the sunset
because question I get is so when do you
rest mmm when did you recover yeah and I
don't want to scare people but the truth
answer is I don't take any days off no
days no seven days a week seven days a
week
look what is it a normal day normal day
for me a normal day so let's say a light
day light day light day is at least a
seven mile run I will
every every fort every other day so
about four days a week um calisthenics
plus gym workout so I don't do any gym
workout without hitting pull-ups
push-ups are called nickels and dimes so
like five pull-ups ten push-ups or I'll
go you know
quarters and whatever likes like 25
pull-ups or in like 50 pushups so I have
all these different things I messed up
so I will do weights with calisthenics
and every single night I stretch for at
least every night I stretch for these
two hours two hours every night every
night so you stretch after you're done
working out yeah so at night time
usually I'll be either in a quiet room
or I'll be watching TV or good I love
sports
I'll be watching the game and I'm on the
floor man and that's what I do
so you just stretch while you're doing
stuff I stress why I do stuff two hours
a long-ass time to stretch is this just
because you're trying to correct all
trying to correct years of not doing
that no years of did you ever [ __ ] with
yoga a lot yeah Yoga says [ __ ] what do
you do huh
I have my own yoga mmm so I kind of in
my own little yoga for what my body
needs I've done hot yoga several times
yoga's huge yoga shoes like holding
those positions you know I'm bigging
holding for a long period of time so
that's where my stretching the other
people said no whole stretches for a
long time I'm holding for a long period
of time I'm trying to get full range of
motion a lot of people going for like
stuck on like my shoulders all messed up
I get surgery on it now if you don't
have full range of motion in your body
don't go in and get cut on man until you
know that your body is actually opened
up you know we start to get knuckle
dragger syndrome from doing ice push-ups
you never work your back you know like
you're like I'm like I'm your rear delts
so here you are you start punching over
before you know it your joints are out
of whack you need to get full range of
motion before you know how [ __ ] up you
truly are hmm so I'm always working on
full range of motion like a kid they run
so effortlessly they're always on full
range of motion as you get older and
tighter and sit and more stressed your
body starts to get more and more tight
therefore your shoulders start to get
out of balance not another joint and on
a socket therefore you know is popping
yeah it's popping because you're [ __ ]
tight open it up first
open it up
you can't can you touch your hands
behind you children and raise them up
behind you you know it's all these
different ranges of motion that I get
real smart on from a guy and I took it
to another level
so are you do you work with a trainer I
do always work out by yourself
everything I do I've never got training
my entire life really never not one time
do you read about physiology or exercise
science or anything like that
nothing nothing nothing but what about
like when they learn new [ __ ] about new
ways to you know enhance shoulder
stability or new exercises you're not
interested no I don't I don't do for
that reason it's till this day man
still this day is to this day it is for
me to become better mentally mmm how I
look has just become a like I have
thousands thousands hundreds of
thousands of miles on this body running
pull-ups push-ups swimming whatever you
wanna call it
this body is what it is now it's from
repetition it's not from studying you
know how if you hold your plank for this
long [ __ ] all that [ __ ] I don't care
about it I just do it for my mind right
I want to continue to harden it because
that's the only thing I want that's what
I want I want to have that mind ready
for life but you also want to increase
your range of motion though yeah razor
motion should make sure that your you
you know you're not causing any
additional injuries dude wouldn't you
want to like stabilize some areas that
maybe feel like you might have
weaknesses and find out new techniques
to do that have you see me with my shirt
off
no yeah this day was [ __ ] Dave got here
early and by the time I got here he was
already doing chin-ups stable state we
do some pull-ups pushed us past some
stable [ __ ] yeah but yeah but you know
all that stuff is very important
honestly just all jokes aside man full
range of motion
getting your shoulder rotation all that
stuff is very important I learned a lot
about that coming up I had a lot of
people I worked out with out there are
real smart about all the stuff I'm a
real old-school meat-eater like Bill
Kazmaier type of lifter you know I look
like it
back when I was that guy
back of the skinny guy that's what I did
and I got off really big into human
performance about the body strength
fitness I said I wanted to be I want to
be a hybrid [ __ ] a guy that can
run 200 miles and then go to the gym
with your meathead who doesn't even
who's scared of running and lifts with
him so that's my whole thing in life I
want to be the guy who can run two miles
with the skinny guys and then go to the
gym with the big medians it's okay
load it up let's go so that was the
whole thing that's a very difficult
thing to tie the two of them together
when you think most people when you
think ultra marathon runners or people
that run long distances is they're very
thin right very thin guys like when you
were talking about the first time you
ran a hundred miles that you did
deadlifts the night before like that is
just [ __ ] preposterous nobody does
that
no yeah so me and the guys talked about
the book it's silverback gorilla is what
I call him in the book I've never doing
him obviously but yeah he saw me going
to my car and not before my first
hundred mile race and you know I was
like he called me out hey Goggins come
here
you know we're Navy SEAL cars yeah I got
to push you through three whole weeks
you're like you know what [ __ ] I gotta
go to gym and lift heavy now so we're
doing squats deadlifts power cleans
heavy bench presses and I'm thinking I
have to run a hundred miles tomorrow but
I also knew he was coming out there to
watch me so I was like you know what you
put me through three whole weeks
you were my instructor so now it's my
turn to educate you on what a human can
do okay I know you could be sitting
there thinking while you're watching me
with your wife and your kid and you
worked out with me not before we went
real heavy did the heaviest [ __ ] were
sore your turn you're gonna sit there
while you watch me run around this
one-mile track how the [ __ ] is he doing
that [ __ ] right now we lifted heavy as
hell and he's running 100 miles and
never has run past 20 miles his life I
use that for a lot of fuel so that gym
workout
mr. silverback gorilla there was a lot
for my mentality that I brought with me
kind knew I would see you and he came at
Mile 50 with a package of six doughnuts
that I chopped up with the quickness
so yeah so I used that workout for a lot
of motivation I knew he'd see me I know
he'd be thinking how'd you not get
wrapped over that that you know what I
don't know what I got that day but I
talked about in the book again that when
I went home that night or that morning
that was single-handedly nothing even
close I'm 43 years old now there's
nothing even close to that pain I knew
for a fact I wasn't we got that tub I
knew I knew I was done I was talked
about dehydrated no nutrition I was
eating wrist crackers and my plex that
was the worst pain I've ever experienced
in my entire life I was pissing
coca-cola out of me it was it was bad it
was bad she probably did have Rob dog
but I guarantee it I I guarantee I'm
missing bad cola that's Coca Cola no
bueno
yeah no bueno saw it was bad and my
ex-wife was like and she you know she's
a nurse
yeah and she called my mom up and mom
had a her friend there was it was it was
a doctor friend of her said hey you got
given to doctor immediately and I was
like eh you got give me that [ __ ]
phone I got called Chris Kaufman let him
know I did 100 miles so I get into bad
water it didn't go as like I feel like I
planned but I did get in the bad water
after another race but uh but didn't you
do a marathon like later so basically I
had never run a marathon right I did the
hundred mile race first no training but
I signed up for the marathon because
it's a first las vegas marathon running
down the strip of las vegas so las vegas
ahead you know had a marathon but it's
the first time is gonna go down the
strip 2005 like hey i wanna sign up for
it i went on to iraq did you know did
deployment when I come back I'll be
training for it and I go do this race
with my family me my ex-wife and my mom
signed up for it so in Iraq me and my
boy sledge in the book we're just
working out very like we're doing crazy
workouts in my cardio was 20 minutes
every Sunday on the elliptical trainer
that's the only cardio I did
so I'll call myself training for this
marathon right so then you know my my
boys got killed in that incident that
happened lone survivor you know the
whole Operation Red Wings so that's what
prompted me to do the hundred mile race
after the hundred mile race in November
it was like two or three weeks later
that marathon that we all signed up for
that didn't train for I didn't train 400
mile race didn't do any training off of
this like hey I'll Drive there with you
all because I tried to run the day
before like I can't even run I can't run
down the block so I didn't do it so we
were driving to the race I said hey mom
my mom's gonna walk it I said I'm gonna
walk it with you my ex-wife I said you
can go ahead and take off do your thing
run your race I don't walk my mom that
gun went off and something [ __ ]
happen what I took up like a jackrabbit
gone that's like what the hell
so I read I was thinking awesome I was
like man I couldn't I tried a hundred
miles like three weeks ago like the
first time ever I was peeing blood and
piss and [ __ ] on myself I go my body's
broken my achilles and my tennis and my
feet are broken I go what is this and
every time I started running further and
further okay I got to the 10k I'm a
Boston Marathon time but God knew the
Boston Marathon I was like 310 59 for my
age I'm like hey on a second and then I
started using all this external [ __ ] for
motivation like okay who the [ __ ] can go
out here and run a hundred miles no
training I'm broken most broken up in my
life now I'm running a marathon who
could do it so I started just feeding
myself feeding myself I get to half the
mile I'm about 30 seconds off the pace I
said hang on man you're Goggins you can
do this [ __ ] man and I started feeding
myself feeding myself feeding myself you
can do this before I knew it man I got
tied to like the last six miles and I
was off the pace and I just kicked it
and that next thing I knew I did like a
308 and change like and that was what
the [ __ ] what have I been leaving on the
table right I've been leaving so much on
the [ __ ] table for pain and that's
when I started like going crazy about
the mine like
what the hell am i tuck what is up I
opened these different doors of like
possibility then like what is humanly
possible what are we capable of like you
know people I didn't even know I was
just amazed by what I was able to do by
a simple fact of just reasoning and
working with pain and pain management
and and my mind has kept on growing from
there
and it happened in hell week it happened
200 my rest happened here and start just
evolving into what it is now to where
now I'm like God man the mind we are
leaving so much on table what people
take me he cusses so much she sounds
crazy
don't listen all that [ __ ] man just just
cut the [ __ ] cut the [ __ ] just
get to the weeds that you are
you are [ __ ] yourself up by not
examining your brain you're not
examining your brain messes it that's
not you examine your [ __ ] brain and
that takes some hard work and suffering
if you're not really do that I'm sorry
and it's usually there's no way to do
that as a bystander no you can't watch
it man yeah you gotta get out there like
oh this hurts this starts real [ __ ]
bad I don't think this is smart and then
guess what happens the body will just it
will adjust if I goes well then the next
question I get but is there a time when
it doesn't adjust I guess some of the
stupidest [ __ ] man like don't don't take
with the grain of [ __ ] salt people's
those questions and people they don't
wanna clip yes yes and that's what I say
when should I quit yeah like did you
ever like feel like no shut the [ __ ] up
stop stop I know what do you like that
there's always that next question no
don't take it like go out there and run
through a brick wall as many times as
you can
no I'm not saying be me don't run tours
in five miles at one time I say and do
that I'm saying start to learn the mind
is powerful it's powerful man it's
unbelievable but if people need they
need a thing to get them going right
they need a thing right I need a goal
they need they need a like it's well
sometimes the first step is the hardest
I think it's hard to take that 1 million
step to but sometimes the first step is
the mole is something about the they
start going over the phone they start
calling people they don't let it out of
the house right it's and there's
something about procrastination it's
like you know it's painful or you know
you should be doing things but you just
keep doing it you keep each in that step
i procrastinate like a [ __ ] man
every day I want to do this [ __ ]
that's what's so funny man people
looking like I'm some damn superhero
that came down from the guys from the
heavens of Earth no man I don't want to
do this [ __ ]
I'm looking at my shoes for 30 minutes
sometimes thinking man
[ __ ] man people people look up to you
Goggins [ __ ] him I'm like I won't do
this [ __ ] man but guess what you do it
I'm gonna do it as long as you do it and
that's what I know about it that's why I
stopped doing I'm thinking oh man you're
gonna [ __ ] sit here you look at your
shoes for 30 or 40 minutes you go you're
gonna think about all day long you go do
it anyway and sometimes you don't have
the time to look at issues for 30
minutes no those are the those are the
beautiful days yes it's you know you
just have to go that's right and so like
there's no room for procrastination and
that's when I when I was in the military
I love my schedule cuz I'm going to be
work at 7 o'clock so you better get your
ass up at 4 o'clock man you get your
[ __ ] in brother because I had to get my
[ __ ] in before I got my [ __ ] in right
you know so that was my mentality back
then man you know like I had to get the
miles and get everything in man and and
get to work man I'm competing with the
alpha males yeah but how much does that
piss other alpha males off that you were
you were imposing a very high bar I I
was a very misunderstood human being
Mouse in the military the Air Force guys
liked me a lot
the Rangers liked me a lot so much not
the seals because they were with you
they they didn't like me so much which
is fine you know I I respect him I think
a lot of and respect a lot of friends in
the SEAL Teams I like I said like
like-minded mentalities as me it wants
to get me I grew up and I got over
a lot of guys still have you know like
they love people can't get over the fact
of whatever
when I became a SIL recruiter a lot of
guys thought I wasn't deploying for a
lot of reasons and whatnot and they I
heard a lot I was that guy who grinded I
grinded hard I mean I I grinded hard I
was that guy who was up like if we went
on an OP or we had a workup let's say we
had a workup we're an island we're out
there shooting guns and doing land
warfare and we did it's like one o'clock
in the [ __ ] morning most everybody go
to sleep I didn't go to sleep
I was the gym and I worked out or I go
asleep and I sent me to be up at 5
o'clock I was up at 4 o'clock and got an
hour in I made sure to always do that
and I I did it to a point to where I
think it pissed some people off because
I I want a quiet person about it you
know I I want the most humble person
always you know so when you're around
alpha males you sometimes picking a
fight you know all the time and I look
different I act different I was
different I am different I take a lot of
pride in that and so you know if if you
didn't get after it I didn't respect you
because I believed that you know where
I'm at I I know that human potential is
what we have it's all we have is what we
the the world sees us a certain way and
when I saw that people weren't doing
that I had a funky ass [ __ ] attitude
and I I owned it in my book I come back
from Ranger school a big time leader I
was a big-time [ __ ] leader I got
honor man out there I led by example and
when I realized a lot of times when
you're in these schools these schools
people want to graduate these schools
because they suck they don't want to
ever go back to these schools mmm those
schools became my [ __ ] life people
don't want to see a [ __ ] God that
wants to go back to day one week one a
[ __ ] Navy so training every [ __ ]
day of your life and that's how I live
and it's a disgusting human being that I
can be it is and a lot of people didn't
like me a lot a lot of [ __ ] people
started some stupid [ __ ] and started
saying this and that bombed lying man is
my [ __ ] resume says
man my resume is out there googling
[ __ ] you say whatever you want
to say about me man I I missed some
diplomas man for having [ __ ] you know
two heart surgeries and people trying to
start some rumors [ __ ] on me man you
started rumor stood on me man because I
[ __ ] got the [ __ ] after it real hard
guys like a guy named hawk I talked to
all time yeah he's a great friend of
mine when the hardest my first before my
heart surgeon my second heart surgeon
I'm a 10-mile run before my second heart
rate the day of it
I want a 10-mile ruck 150 pounds I saw
that guy he's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing out here we got a heart surgeon
Roger that brother I'm getting him
before him be out for about six months
after the heart surgery God's my
mentality because I started realizing at
a young age when I was leading on the
table and once I found out what a human
being is capable of I didn't know how to
control that I was I was a [ __ ] you
want talk about [ __ ] Savage that's
what I was I was a [ __ ] straight-up
people talk about Savage very likely I
was [ __ ] from the back woods
[ __ ] Savage dude you know and
this I was just I was I told you what I
thought I had eight chips on my shoulder
I and a lot of times that wasn't great
so is it a situation where like with the
seals where once you've gotten through
buds and once you've gotten through all
the the physically grueling parts of
getting to be accepted once you're in
then you were imposing standards that
they didn't wanna they didn't want to
keep up with I would say some people you
know I had a I had one platoons I had
the problem with you know like I like I
I graduate Ranger School and I and I got
in a spittoon and I didn't see out of
hockey I was in charge with PT program
and you put me in charge the PT program
is [ __ ] your ass and the thing about
it is I didn't like it either
how do you I don't want to do this [ __ ]
either man but what were you making them
do like you know like I it was some Navy
it was some budget you know we went back
to bus like you know long pts and you're
carrying logs over the berms and [ __ ]
and like I'd had us do like
pull-ups rope climbs pull-up like like
out of like an hour so imagine doing a
rope climb then go over dudes like 10 to
15 pull-ups coming back and we would do
like these if they were
very hard workouts like there was no
like go to the gym lift some weights
type of [ __ ] and I was imposing my own
mentality on everybody
these are grown-ass [ __ ] men you know
you know they don't want to be what I'm
trying to make them to be and when they
called me off like hey you know we're
not in silt you know we're not buds
anymore Goggins it pissed me off
and I and I got a little [ __ ]
attitude got my chip and I got my ball
and meet me and sleds went ahead and
started to work out together and we
developed this like me and sleds workout
like [ __ ] Garanimals and we had this
[ __ ] mentality of [ __ ] yeah we're
doing every day and everyone's kind of
did their own thing man and I just
that's when I started looking at people
you know not just see people very
differently Matt because I've been in to
like you know like to be the special
operator you gotta have broken legs and
these guys all those stories I was the
same guy man I I put people on a
pedestal I put people I can never be
them I can never be that guy man never
put anybody at pedestal that's what
happened to me I put him on a pest and
once I got up there with him and I saw
him and it wants to get not everybody
some hard [ __ ] out there do you
period dot hard [ __ ] I thought
he every [ __ ] was hard
hey-ya uncommon amongst uncommon man
that's all it was about for me man and I
took it to another level and I pissed a
lot of [ __ ] off and they were
trying to find chinks in my armor then
they were they were trying to find
chinks in the armor
you know all he does is run all he does
is [ __ ] run that's why I you know but
once again I smell talk about the
military too much like I said the Air
Force loved me the army guys I work with
love me the Ranger school all that stuff
love me and I wasn't you know it's just
what it is man it's a I was part of the
Navy SEALs I was at I was a team guy but
I wasn't part of the Brotherhood and
that's just me man that's just me it
ain't any say nothing bad about them I
got a lot of love for a lot of them love
my men got love for me vengo talk bad
about them
it's just I'm different it definitely I
figured out I'm different from everybody
in the [ __ ] world and I had to own
that and say you know what man you made
a lot of
the mistakes being it's being who you
are and I should have been more of a
leader at times but a lot of times a lot
of people should've been a little bit
harder - so was it that some of those
guys just didn't want to work as hard or
was it just that they were they weren't
appreciating how competitive you were
you were always against them is that
what it was that it didn't foster the
sense of brotherhood because you were
more like come on [ __ ] I didn't really
call them [ __ ] but you can look at my
face and I looked at you and in your you
can you can kind of say this you know so
what happens I started developing this
like this separation another thing about
me - maths I don't go out I don't party
I don't hang out with the guys I don't
you know so I was always forming this
kind of separation I'm a big time
introvert you know I do my job and I
want to see your [ __ ] ass again I'm
gonna go home
refresh and we'll see you again you know
you're here enough patooties guys four
to two years sometimes year and a half
and I would you know we work up do our
[ __ ] and I I just I was just a different
[ __ ] cat I'm a different cat man like
I uh you know I just I I think
differently I believe differently and I
believe strongly what I believe in when
some people must appreciate the fact
that were self-motivated and that you
were pushing the envelope that you were
pushing the face you were setting a high
bar yeah I have a lot of guys right now
within the community a lot of a lot of
guys once again this is like it's like a
big so proper sometimes man when you
know when we when you in a fraternity
like that that's what it's like man so I
had to get a different vantage point
look at it and see like you know a lot
of guys did respect who I was and what I
did and I I brought it [ __ ] hard a
lot and every day but I also rubbed
people the wrong way I'm like that
you're talking about I'm like that is
you want to scratch the [ __ ] on my ass
you're gonna like [ __ ] this dude man I
love what you talked about when you ran
the marathon you realize how much you
were leaving on the table because that
is um I mean I think the the unfulfilled
potential is the story of most people's
lives
it is it is it and it could have been
the story of mine I tell a lot of people
people go what's your biggest fear in
life and my biggest fear honestly was
let's say this let's say I don't care if
you believe in God or now I don't care
so this this is play game with me let's
say let's say you're God and we have a
big [ __ ] long line of people and I
made to heaven 75 years old I'm 300
pounds I made to heaven I worked for
Ecolab my entire life spraying for
cockroaches that's what I did but I'm
dead I'm in heaven now and you are at
your you're judging us all now so we're
in line we're all sitting there in line
you have Adam Brown here's a big board
up and you're talking to Adam Brown
about his life and you rip it down and
I'm next in line
David Goggins I see my name I see all
this [ __ ] and God goes hey you say read
this man now I'm reading this list and
I'm seeing 182 pounds Navy SEAL Ranger
School motivational speaker changing
lives okay man I pull up record all this
[ __ ] I'm like that's not me man
and God looks at me and says house who
you were supposed to be and my biggest
fear I visualized some crazy [ __ ] my
biggest fear is that one day I want to
reach a judgment of my life someone
something is gonna judge me what the
[ __ ] I was supposed to be in life and
what I want now is that whoever's judge
me would ever judge me up there I want
them to have a board in them up there
right now getting their pin out because
you know this person who's judging us
know everything supposed to know from
the time you're dead the time you know
you know time you're born tons of dead I
want this person up there to be like
this up there write more about me saying
[ __ ] I know you could do that I I don't
do that so I want to impress whatever
the [ __ ] is up there whatever's going on
in life I want to go up there and not
have anything left on the table I want
to I want to drain my soul of every
[ __ ] bit of person I am now how do
you plan on doing that but going forward
in the future do you have a plan yeah so
what I did I
I believe in going back to scratch so a
lot of us like right now I've come a
long way in my life I've had to grow up
a lot except a lot of the [ __ ] things
I've done in my life I'd accept a lot I
took all this information big database
took it all so what got me to be where
I'm at today is data I collect even more
data now is where I can write this book
which I can tell people hey you know I
[ __ ] have a lot of faults I have a
other mentality that can sometimes what
people draw all this [ __ ] so how you get
better is so right now I'm way up here
now I was way down here but what makes
you way up here is being from way down
here so I love going back I call it so
when I was growing up for like three
years so from time I was eight to time I
was like twelve we lived in a $7 a month
place and what I call it is I'm always
paying rent in that $7 a month home
every day of my life
I go back and revisit that place because
that place made me this garanimal that
place made me this hard man and then
from that place so that place is hard
work that place is going back to the
fundamentals of life the fundamentals
what made David Gaga's David Gaga's
going back in there going back to the
going back to the library of David
Goggins studying even more - I know
taking that out going back to our map
now and then moving forward so I believe
in always taking steps backwards - to
your roots we cannot forget the roots
and what made us the garanimal we can
never become civil law isn't a garanimal
they're like the little kids clothes
it's a little kids clothes but I love
the word
I love his clothes or drinks I know the
clothes or drinks man but something like
that so when when you when you live in
like right now like what kind of goals
are you setting and how you how are you
how are you feeding that beast inside of
you how are you calming all that down
stretching supped a lot you know so when
you wire yourself up so much yoga yoga
and stretching has really helped me to
like you want to be quiet in your mind
to see what you want to go because noise
is the ultimate kryptonite down too much
noise in your mind you're not going to
be focused on with the task
and is it's one things that I found
there like long cardio so the best thing
ever for harming that noise yes we all
talked about that all the guys that I
did that so October thing with the
fitness challenge that wake if you
workout five hours a day you don't give
a [ __ ] no it's it's amazing I'm like if
you could take that and put it in a pill
form how you feel about life after you
workout five hours yep we don't give a
[ __ ] nothing bothers you nothing you
nothing because you struggled true my
fiancee right now it's okay I got XYZ
and like I'll take you
she's like what you want look at shoes
I'll take you and what like I just
worked out for four hours man okay sit
down this [ __ ] chair all day
long and son yeah yeah I'm chill it's
different yeah I get all that [ __ ] out I
wring the rag out in the morning time
and whatever you want to do I'm here man
most people never get there though no
they always have that chatter always is
negative anger of the guy cut you off
yesterday at all day long ahead yep all
day long man chatter chatter chatter
maybe I should do this maybe I should
have done that I should never let that
guy get away with that exact should have
done this I should have taken that job
you know I should have moved I should
stuck with her
that was me man that was my people yeah
most people like me amazing that that
long cardio just calms that chatter like
that yes I got I never until October
I've never really done long cardio every
day it beat that testosterone up man
beats everything else yeah that's just
you're like [ __ ] done yeah you're
cool yeah you're cool man
it's not just that it's like it's I
always talk about people's brains that I
think that the the way people's minds
work that we're like a battery that's
like leaking out it's like since we
don't use it because we have all this
potential we don't use it like it uses
off the top of the batter and it gets
messy right it's going down the sides of
the battery it's all [ __ ] up yeah but
one you just drain that [ __ ] like
nature intended like give you the
potential to run away from predators
avoid invading tribes and to fight and
gather and hunt and all the physical
potential that your body is capable of
when you do drain
with like a ten-mile run or alright long
cardio session long workout session then
you can just be you it's the Great Purge
man the purge
it's a purge you purge all that [ __ ]
demon [ __ ] out man all the evil evil
can't stay in a ten-mile run bro let's
go get leaked right the [ __ ] out pound
it out yeah but you could see things
clip more clearly and that is only
available through effort I mean maybe
it's available through meditation I
don't know but I feel like there's a
different thing that's available through
effort because there's also a
satisfaction of accomplishment oh yeah
efforts huge man it means everything
guess you gotta feel good about yourself
now what do you do you plan out your
future I do so I'm very go so I have
that accountability mirror but I also
plan on all my small big time you know
medium goals all these things I have to
do in life I'm a big planner I'm a big
planner so you know right now I'm going
back to scratch so I'm trying to be
wildland firefighter you know I did that
for a couple seasons you're gonna do
that now yeah so I did it for I did it
for to not not full season but but but
to half season so this year was my
second year doing it I had to I had to
stop about two months before it ended
because this book to start promoting the
book I started finishing the book up but
I've been doing the opportunity that's
some [ __ ] work man
those [ __ ] guys get half what made
you decide to do that the work you know
like when your hands stop becoming
really calloused it's time to get back
to work you know like I retired from the
military I did 21 years in the military
the military was my life loved
everything about it the discipline of it
there's some about going back in the and
the money you make is nil it's not about
the money at all it's just about the
hard work I've always been looking for
those people like those guys it's like
you're out there digging a 3-mile fire
line literally a three-mile fire line
you're cutting down these [ __ ] huge
ash trees to dig this fire line and the
fire line is like 20 to 18 inches it for
for three miles
you got like [ __ ] 12 people digging
this [ __ ] and I'm either thinking man
this time the hardest [ __ ] work I've
done in my life and it's that challenge
that you can't find sometimes
by going to the gym or about running you
know 100 mile race if that if that new
challenge of like hey and you get done
digging alright
you've worked 17 hours 16 17 hours you
get your [ __ ] little [ __ ] sleeping
mat out shack down boom right on the
floor right there on the ground get up
dig some more you know be out there two
three weeks sometimes man that's doing
that [ __ ] and there's great satisfaction
and the kind of work that you do out
there no one's watching no one gives a
[ __ ] it's hard dangerous [ __ ] work
and you know you're doing it to help
[ __ ] out man you know how did you get
drawn into that so I got drawn into it
because I was always looking for the
next challenge
now as I kept what is there after the
military what the [ __ ] is it man I'm 43
I'm getting back into shape you know I'm
[ __ ] getting these health issues for
taking care of that I had and I started
once again Google is amazing [ __ ]
hardcore [ __ ] jobs you know pretty
much you know hard hard ass [ __ ] you
know that's I found the horse you know
like the first race you know hardest
races in the world so basically I
started find this wildland firefighter
like what the [ __ ] is wild land
firefighting so our googling that start
googling smokejumpers you know I'm like
what the [ __ ] these guys do what they
jump out of planes and attack small
fires like that's the [ __ ] so I'm like
okay okay we could put down a list and
okay hotshot so it was a hotshot dude
they go out but you know big fires and
they dig fire line I'm like [ __ ] with
dick from it and that's all video of it
like that [ __ ] looks like it sucks it's
hot you know there's you know you're out
you're on your own
I mean you know you're out there on your
own man just digging fire lines so
that's kind of how I found it I'm always
looking for the next challenge I'm never
satisfied with oh I did that like you
know I became a seal I was an Air Force
guy became a seal I went to Ranger
School I tried out for Delta Force twice
you know like I'm always looking for
wood is next looking for those uncommon
men and women uncommon people so I'm
trying to I'm trying to grow I'm trying
to grow and a lot of times you know you
won't be the only person that's making
yourself grow you're looking for those
cameron Haines's those joe rogan those
people who are like just different
people who understand what the [ __ ]
you're saying because a lot of things
I have to say I can't save them all I
can't save them all you may not
understand them so I had to really find
a way to communicate with people so they
don't think oh my god like what what'd
you just say
so these Cameron Haynes is these joy
these people get it so I go in those
little those little nuclear spots get a
little more strengthing a little more
knowledge get little more tools take
those tools with me put in my tool shed
and I go off gone you know down the road
on a new journey so that's what I do
well the proof is in the pudding if
you're really doing woodland
firefighting cuz there's no glory in
that no sir no there's no fame there's
no there's no one taking pictures of you
no and that paycheck is small I'm a
[ __ ] Mickey why don't you shot eat
today
Wow yeah there's there's nothing
involved in that man they work their ass
off so but you're just doing it as a
challenge that's it
does they freak out when you're there
you know what I I think they're one and
why is a 43 year old retired man you
know all the stuff you've done why are
you out here yeah and I explained it to
him I'm out here I'm out here you know
to learn from you all to grow and also
to never forget where I came from you
know that's where it starts it's that
mentality if I'm gonna pick up that
[ __ ] Pulaski and I'm gonna dig this
[ __ ] fire line for three damn miles
that's that mentality I never want to
lose I never want to get so nicer at oh
yeah I did it man I did it I did it I'm
good yeah that mentality of I'm willing
to pick up that shovel and I'm willing
to dig a three-mile line it's there's
some about that mentality that I'm ready
to go to work at anytime and that's what
keeps me those are the sparks like you
know I look at motivation that's just a
spark it's like it's like kindling you
know how a big fire starts it starts
with a little smoke it started a little
cigarette being thrown in the woods next
thing to all Californians [ __ ] burn
up that's what I've been doing my whole
life as I find these little sparks and
once that little thing takes off that's
a that's a one hour fuel then you got
ten hour fuel then you can move that
thing - a
in our fuel these big logs and big trees
that burn for days and that's where you
want to bring that motivation that's how
you want to bring that drive so if you
have no King lean the kindling is me
going out with these young guys saying
all right [ __ ] 43 it's a 20 year
old keep up with them that kindling now
when I leave those young guys it has now
become that 10 hour fuel and now that
$10,000 a few that I used throughout my
whole life I use that to my whole life
but hey this summer 43 you went out
there and you did that man so you know
you're not giving up yet you're not done
yet not today
you're not done today that's a crazy
choice to make though woodland
firefighters a very interesting choice
it is it is it's a nasty job man because
again that's the proof of concept like
you're really just doing just for the
struggle that's it
there's other things you considered like
that um so I will I apply for
smokejumping this year so I'll be out
smokejumping this year you know God
willing that's where it's at now that
right now is my next military that's my
next military and that's it's always
about human growth it's not about money
not about money human growth that's the
biggest like I said my biggest trophy
that's why I turned down $300,000 the
biggest trophy in life is what I've
learned like this brain if I could put
this brain in somebody's head and said
here you go Merry Christmas
they'd be a happy person well I found
out is that with no crowds no one
cheering for you no race is no finish
line it's an amazing amazing thing I've
learned in my mind by no one cheering
you on like what that is is every
morning I do what I do I don't have a
trainer waking me up there's no one
saying David you have to do this I don't
have to do anything anymore
I've done it that's the beauty of all
this knowing that everything I talk
about no one even knows what the [ __ ]
I'm doing every day and I know that I am
grinding like a [ __ ] they see a
one-minute video
I mean running there's some [ __ ]
hopefully it motivates you Merry
Christmas dude I'm out there for [ __ ]
hours
every [ __ ] day and no one sees what
the [ __ ] I'm doing no one it's a great
beautiful thing man that is the
beautiful thing about it right that you
really are just doing it for the
benefits of it that's it that you have
to do it that way it's not for show like
there's a lot of people like you'll see
like they have a little video Lee do on
Instagram like [ __ ] you are not doing
that for very long no and too fast
that's it I got my one minute on yeah
okay now yeah yeah yeah exactly
it's so much a visit for show I do enjoy
those videos that you're doing on
Instagram though we appreciate these
little motivational things I put some of
them up on my page I appreciate you
posted it there's are those are those
are great man like what do you are you
just like do you just get a thought in
your head while you're out there running
and you just want to get it down yeah so
what I'll do is I my fiancee there's all
these videos man so god bless you it's
something to be three o'clock in the
[ __ ] morning and I'll be working out
that's the hey wake the [ __ ] up I got
some [ __ ] hey what hey man it came to me
man I got some [ __ ] for these people man
that's what happens I usually when I'm
working out I get this great inspiration
I some people might think it's [ __ ]
but my mind works best under extreme
pain and suffering like oh my god I
wanna be out here and that's what I'm
going deep into the cellar of my mind
and that's when all that gargoyle [ __ ]
starts to come up man you know I'm Sam
and so she gets called out all the time
like hey I'll run home and say hey get
the car
meet me at 17th Street because by that
time I have all my [ __ ] together so
that's all this happens man it's not
like a rehearsed thing that's why
sometimes I may post on Monday uses like
every Monday but sometimes it's Tuesday
sometimes it's Thursday you know I and
that's what I do I I'm trying to now
give back to people in a way that's real
and authentic and just being me what
does the response been like like after
you did the podcast the first time what
was a response like and was the response
like on social media what was crazy man
is that you are my sure and I'm [ __ ]
Bieber that's the [ __ ] response man
so your crowd for some reason they they
resonate with me
they understand they they they they get
me and they they love the message and
like so if you put some [ __ ] up on
my site I block and delete your ass this
ain't this ain't a playground like like
my site I'm not [ __ ] around with you
[ __ ] I want to give you some
tools that I learn if you want to take
them tango if not Merry Christmas I'll
go on my merry way I don't care so if
you go on there you want to play around
you want to you know well there's but it
caught up those people going slow troll
[ __ ] you on my [ __ ]
I'm gonna block your monkey ass off my
[ __ ] quick I want so I've been friends
Jamie yeah tell him so I've developed
like a small community of people who can
go in there and it's not just me talking
so people have now joined in and there
I've seen people who's a hundred and
fifty pounds on my site man like and
they're in there writing about and
they're starting to break themselves
down like I broke myself down like a I
went through this I went through this
divorce and this happened and I tried to
kill myself it gets wrong and then
people are now going on and commenting
on their [ __ ] saying hey keep it up do
what you're doing it's become like a big
[ __ ] like hey it's a community of
people trying to [ __ ] get better and
that's what it's about man it's saying
about the David Goggins [ __ ] show nah
man I'm mr. King lien you [ __ ]
take this [ __ ] and let it burn also you
probably need all these other people out
there grinding - for fuel oh man I want
to know that's the thing now like people
go what motivates you now what motivates
me now is that there's over 600 some
1000 people looking at me saying
[ __ ] Goggins is somewhere out
there he saw her out there [ __ ]
getting after it and I am so you ain't
never [ __ ] alone I'm out there
somewhere yeah six hundreds of thousand
people there's a chance that when you're
working out on care if you're a [ __ ]
Washington DC and I'm in Nashville
there's a good chance the same time
we're getting after it and I want people
know that and that's the real deal
we are getting after together not know
like happy family [ __ ] but we're getting
after it you know yeah well that is
that's giant for people man that the
sense of community and to know that
there's like-minded folks out there
they're also trying to improve the
journey over
their own demons get past their own
[ __ ] wash their own weaknesses cows
up their own mind I love that you know
it's not time for some soft [ __ ] it's
not type of soft [ __ ] man this isn't the
[ __ ] playground don't come on my
Instagram Facebook or Twitter talking
some [ __ ] come on if you want to if
you want to join the community and get
hard and see what you're about don't
talk about rest you know how do you do
it no that's [ __ ] stop thinking so
much and let's put the shoes on and get
grinded you do get some of that though
some comments to say you know this is
terrible advice rest and recovery is not
my site yeah I hear that [ __ ] there's a
lot of people looking for built-in
excuse AR man they are there looking for
it but then there's a lot of people also
that are just really interested in
personal growth they're interested in
really finding out what they're made of
they're interested in improving their
ability to toughen up and try to put
themselves and they're looking they're
looking for people like you and other
people just add to that momentum right
once you get going it's easier to keep
going that's it man once you get going
it's easier to keep showing up it is it
is you have to get past that hurdle yeah
you want to get past it man you're
flying and then you see other people
that are doing it too and you realize
like this is a this is a movement
there's a lot of other people out there
it is a movement yeah it is a movement
well that's the thing that resonates
with you I think about the audience of
this podcast that I've had quite a few
people on that have that same message
and it resonates with people because
we're all trying to improve ourselves no
one's perfect
nope there's no I'm not perfect now and
never will be you're not and you never
will be but you're better than you were
yesterday and you're gonna be better
tomorrow that's the truth day right
there man and that's what that book says
I am NOT [ __ ] perfect man I had the
balls to now finally tell you all I'm
very flawed but in that saying that
you're very flawed in saying that you're
very perfect you exhibit way more
strength than someone who bullshit's and
pretends right someone who puts up some
fake-ass [ __ ] fake facade of
perfection right of moral integrity and
growth and honesty and those people are
a real problem
it's exhausting sometimes a [ __ ] yeah I
did it for a while I'm [ __ ] up I give
up I quit I quit I quit I'm [ __ ] up
I'm gonna tell you all I can't live this
anymore this is who I am but the
confidence of you of constantly grinding
and constantly putting in that work is
what leads you to be able to express
yourself so honestly oh you're right I I
for the first time believe in David
Goggin
and I don't care who else believes in me
I don't care for the first time my life
me I could tell you all my [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and without lying that's powerful
no longer care that's powerful they see
everybody could get to that then you do
you don't have any excuses because you
don't need any that's right
no need any to me none you'll like me
Merry Christmas Kwanzaa keep moving yes
it go yeah good luck to you
exactly yeah we're all on this thing
together yeah you got your own path no
one wants to stare at those shoes for 30
minutes that's so true man so true so
fire jumping and woodland firefighting
that didn't expect that I didn't hear
that coming
yeah that's interesting man yep and what
did you have any other options that you
were looking at before you dived into
those you know what those are the first
that came up because I saw how hard it
was you know like at 43 and these jobs
like like in the military you're a
dinosaur time to retire and while in
firefighting you know you started moving
to these desk jobs mm-hmm and that was
the challenge of it you know I'm like
I'm like a [ __ ] rookie at 43 right so
I'm like being talked like a little
[ __ ] so it takes a lot for me you know
I'm like mm I've done some things man
hang on now but I have to now humble
myself again right it's hard to humpy
stuff you got some 21 year old little
punk-ass [ __ ] saying hey pick up that
[ __ ] and come on like but what the [ __ ]
you say I'm like you know I'm like okay
Gaga it's like you're a rookie man like
so that's all the training behind the
mindset of it all right is that you
can't ever be the point you never learn
from people right you know you have to
always humble yourself and go back to
that yeah you know like right now
there's people listing this podcast like
oh yeah you're great guys no you ain't
[ __ ] Goggins and that's the mindset I
always when I have no like I'm not proud
of myself
but you have to always keep that like I
want to keep that dog in me mmm and I
can't always know everything
yeah well being a beginner at something
that's fantastic it's amazing being
learning new things is fantastic for
everything else so much growth in that
have you do you [ __ ] around with martial
arts you know what I learned a little
bit I've never gone crazy in it I've
never gone crazy
I boxed a little bit where do you live I
live in Nashville it's a lot of
jiu-jitsu in Nashville you should get
involved in jiu-jitsu you look like a
duck to water
I'll find you a spot yeah yeah yeah I'm
fine you spot you you get obsessed with
that [ __ ] oh god is that so yeah
never-ending pile of [ __ ] tangled
bodies and struggle here we go because
it's something that you just get better
at all the time and there's no hiding
right either you get choked or you don't
either you survive or you don't
I've been a lot of ground a lot of
ground gangs man but I've never really
learned the skill sets yeah so it would
be nice to do that I'll hook it up yeah
please do I think you would get obsessed
with it the same way Jacko's obsessed
with it see what other seals get
obsessed with martial arts it would be
nice to do it because it's also constant
competition as well I mean you can get
into competition every single night of
the week really and yeah absolutely and
as a guy who's just starting out you're
gonna be a white belt you're gonna get
strangled a lot you want to choke the
[ __ ] out from the beginning
you're gonna start from the beginning of
a hundred percent guys your size there's
plenty of guys who have been doing it
for [ __ ] decades no law guys like the
hands on me so I'll be good yeah Goggins
you're coming huh okay but it's also a
good thing to have the kind of cardio
and endurance you have - yeah that's
where I get people that I've rolled with
a lot of guys who have skills mm-hmm but
the thing that I really have and I'm
like a brag on it man I got a [ __ ] up
cardio base man I got a [ __ ] up cardio
base man and my mentality is kind of
[ __ ] up - yeah so I realized that was
fighting that if you got a big cardio
base and you're mindsets [ __ ] up - mmm
cardio is almost everything
skills are everything because a lot of
guys with skills also have some cardio
they have a night [ __ ] you up
right but to have true
this cardio with big skills is
everything I see him man dying
yeah because so many guys started 100%
but three minutes into the fight they're
at 80 right you know five minutes into
the fight they're at 60 that's right and
they recover for a minute they come back
but if you're if you are in like a
rolling session like when you roll your
roll for nine minutes straight
so you and this guy and you there's most
of the time there's multiple taps all
right you'll tap him he'll tap you you
tap each other but nine minutes man it
is exhausting when that bell goes off
the last you know the the Bell for 30
seconds and you got 30 seconds left in
nine minutes and then dinging it's over
you're like you've done and then you
take a minute off you find a new partner
that's good [ __ ] back in there you love
it it sounds like a good grind yeah
that's the next grind right there you
love it yeah no hey someone that take
about if I went like this hard at it
it's hard to say because it depends
entirely upon how much emphasis you put
on learning new techniques and rolling
and drilling drilling is gigantic and
that's the thing that people don't like
to do because jiu-jitsu so fun people
like to just roll right because it's a
sparring is where it's at like I don't
want to do this practice I want to choke
people like I knew a few things like do
that okay okay let me get in there then
you want it's like a lot of jujitsu
schools they'll start out with like one
or two techniques and then you roll most
of the class is just sparring right but
the right way to do it really is to
drill way more than you spar because
you'd be drilling all the time and live
drilling to like you start out where a
guy has your back
ready go and then from there you got to
try to escape and do it the right thing
to try to use the right technique to get
out of that position or you'll start out
with an armbar but he's defending and
you got to figure out how to extend it
you know in those live drills straight
drills like technique drills and then
live drills or I think even more
important in the beginning to to your
personal development and growth as a
jiu-jitsu player then even sparring but
a guy like you who's smart and tough and
will go crazy [ __ ] it shouldn't take
that long it takes people I mean it
depends on how much you did
get yourself to all right PJ pen got his
black belt in three years
what yeah but it's crazy he's BJ Penn
he's so like the prodigy for a reason
right right I had a conversation with
him about though it was really
interesting once he he goes he was
talking to some other dude and the guy
said I got my black belt at three years
just like you did BJ and he's like wow
man he goes you must be good he goes no
man he goes I'm addicted just like you
he goes you were addicted you're
addicted and he's like I never thought
about it that way goes yeah I'm addicted
to jujitsu so addicted like it takes
over your mind right it's everything
your days are spent thinking about some
guy who triangled you this [ __ ]
how do you get me [ __ ] like I get that
today I got choked out ten years ago
that I think about sometimes when I'm
lifting I'll be tired and I'll think
about a guy who caught me ten years ago
I [ __ ] yeah that was great about life
man yeah I think about not being choked
out but I think about a lot of [ __ ] like
that yeah pushing they grind on me like
a [ __ ] man and that's what
you're talking about earlier - it's like
that the mind has these reserves you can
trick it and pull them out yes
inspirational reserves like you did when
when you when you guys were going
through buds yes we just found that
trigger and then all sudden you throwing
that boat in the air the mind always has
the tactical advantage over you why is
it it knows your fears those
insecurities it knows where they're
hiding can't hide can't hide that
[ __ ] man
I'm not forget the tactical advantage on
you son that's gonna get you man it's a
beast that might be your best lesson
right that your mind your mind knows
everything you cannot hide from it so
don't ever try don't try neither go and
beat that [ __ ] I gotta keep
going at it that's also what you did in
this book you didn't try to like paint
yourself in a glamorous or flattering
way at any point in time you were honest
at every step of the way which i think
is just gigantic for people too because
you can tell when someone's stroking
themselves or [ __ ] themselves and
the messages won't come through right
but this you're you come through in this
book you know like you who you are and
what you became and how you became who
you are and who you used to be
and why you were the way you used to be
all that comes through it's like there's
no filter this is just your your
thoughts like you what you remember
about your life and what you think about
right now just all comes out onto the
pages hardest thing I've done my entire
life I'm a Mangin I have [ __ ] on the
Hager by this book then then I walk up
to people people walk up to me I like
what you thinking about [ __ ]
[Laughter]
hey how about you [ __ ]
tell me something bout you that's what
people love right when they know some
[ __ ] about you don't know nothin about
nobody
that's anonymous trolls that's it man
and they get at me they come how there's
a lot of those but they're all doing
that to themselves they don't even
understand when you do that you're doing
it to yourself right if you are
attacking someone because you know that
they have a weakness but you're
pretending you don't have one you are
attacking yourself you are chipping away
your own personal sovereignty you're
chipping away your own respect so true
man can't respect yourself you know
you're a [ __ ] that's what happened
though Joe to me I start looking at
people realizing I know something about
you because they don't want to talk
about it right I already know it yeah if
you're talking [ __ ] about me yeah I know
you're [ __ ] up yeah that's what all
these cats that come out right now who
don't like me whatever like really man
that should happen thirty [ __ ] years
ago fifteen years ago you still you
still [ __ ] up about that oh man I'm
gonna something bout you brother
is that get over everything I'm good
it's water out of the [ __ ] brain just
grind it's the grind doesn't use is it I
said you're not grinding hard if if
you're worried about something that
someone did to you years ago you're
being a [ __ ] to yourself may not
getting out there and squeezing that
[ __ ] soul out every day yeah if you
grind hard man I got ton of what about
your monkey ass I ain't got time about
you man cuz tomorrow I got to go back to
the grind and tomorrow I go back to the
grind again and again and again again
I don't have time to put you into the
hate bank there's no hate it's all
filtered out man through the grind if
you don't get it there's there's great
joy in the grind the great join to
suffer it's it's totally cleanses your
body out man if any kind of hate makes
you grow up it's also the being honest
about it every step of the way the way
you are in this book and the way you are
we talk about things you're not not
trying to paint yourself in a flattering
way no it forces you to continue to
perform right by exposing all the [ __ ]
that you used to do by exposing your
procrastination your slips your feather
your fallings your falling back down and
getting fat again all that stuff it
forces you to be consistent like you
know you did it today you know you did
it today do you know you're gonna be
able to do it tomorrow
well you have to yes all right no that's
not you know that's my biggest fear man
is that I know I could slip everybody's
bad you're not permanent [ __ ]
no one's permanent almost [ __ ]
permanent that's why people that have
accomplished great things and then want
to talk about those great things to the
end of time and not do anything anymore
no they're [ __ ] themselves is it
those people that are looking for that
golden age okay for that holding hands
and walking off into the south and I
read its role that doesn't exist it's
not tattooed man it's not real I thought
it was tattoos I like [ __ ] I'm slipping
I'm like what I put all this repetition
and I'm still slipping can't take a day
off man can't take a day off man take a
days a week I get after I see the thing
about I do active recovery right okay so
what so what's a light active recovery
day you see seven days seven miles is
normal easy six mile run that's active
recovery and a low low heart rate I look
like I'm walking I'm off to like a
[ __ ] 9:30 10-minute mile heart rate
real low I'm really big into the heart
rate training man it's amazing so it
makes you a machine it makes you a
machine man how so it won't work it
trains your heart in a way that the way
I was able to run these hundred mile
races like I was able to do it was off a
heart rate so if you go at 80 percent
for me for the longest time I was like
100 like 147 heart rate 148 to 150 to
running run in there if I maintain that
man I'm in that I'm burning that nice
fat storage and that body wants to
utilize that and it wants to burn that
nice and slow and you never getting that
heart rate up her hockey the hurry up or
high takes a lot to recover from that
and the higher goes the longer it takes
her to come down when I stayed at 145
146 147 heart rate for a long time when
I get done running it will go back under
a hundred within two or three minutes
and that's what you want you want that
quick recovery
so a quick recovery means that that's
your body's right on point and I look at
my and my heart rate the morning time
it's using the 30s if it's like 45 46 47
I'm over trained
easy day each day means Zone one so I'm
one means I'm it's going real light
today so I trained every day because why
as my mind and as a human we're supposed
to move every day I'm supposed to move
and I'm not saying get after it every
day get after me just do something every
day right ride a bike like if you're
real tired from working out hard right
an easy bike spin and as you're spinning
take in your fluids rehydrate your body
as you're acting cuz that's the best way
to rehydrate your body and like taking
the carbohydrate drink it gets all that
good carbs you start to glycogen store
your body again for the next day so as
you're doing active stuff that Bloods
flowing now
active blood flow nice active blood flow
helps the recovery process along with
drinking some some like endurance drink
or some carbohydrate drink it gets all
that glycogen through the system back to
the muscles loads them back up again
ready to fight another war tomorrow what
do you use for a heart rate monitor I
usually use polar for a long time
and I kind of still use polar now is
that a wrist one our chester has a chest
strap it's a nice cheap little chest
strap and now I'm at a point now where I
know I only do my heart rate in the
morning time I don't even wear it we're
not run anymore do you check it whether
the strap in the morning or yeah check
your finger check the stress so you wake
up you just put the strap on before you
get it back put the strap on your body
mmm you don't the first thing you do put
a strap on or do your finger but
everyone you can do if I have a strap do
your finger know what your average heart
rate is you know your resting heart rate
and then from there if it's a little bit
high low elevated you know you can't go
off into that zone 3 zone for training
day
you got to or zone 1 so it's all about
the heart rate the resting heart rate so
when you use it the chest strap does it
register on an application on a phone
like how do you read it on the watch on
a watch is it a smart watch or as a
polar walk it's a polar watch so it's a
watch that shows you the heart rate
that's reading off the strap exactly
that's all it does and so when you say
zone ones this is these are the things
that you've created zone ones onto the
know these are like zones that uh that's
no whoever created this like like the
heart rate zone training so basically
what I did in was help me out so much is
my zone two training runs used to beat
8:30 okay so that was my pace at like a
145 mile yep a 30 mile through
stretching and get my body opened up my
zone to run now is about a seven twenty
one seven eighteen seven nineteen so it
kind of minute off just by kissing up
your range push up my range of motion
Wow unbeliev
our tray so my stride if people look at
videos of me like years ago I was first
in my first bad water look I was
scooting I have like it was so tight I
look like I was this this very rigid
runner now I actually run
you know everything was so tight
everything was that contact forming it I
was like I'm like like my knees and my
George is going inward now everything's
right you know we're needs to be at and
I have a nice long nice Drive do you run
on the street
I'm on Spartan for the most part I'm
always traveling and so the best thing
you do gets your running shoes you get
your [ __ ] you just go out and run but I
you know some dirt as much as possible
yeah so it's really good for you but now
my body is like [ __ ] second I got
iron I mean it is it can take some
beating
now when you when you run if you ever
[ __ ] with those barefoot running shoes
no no no you know what look honestly I
don't know many people who have been I
don't believe in it I don't believe it I
was born with shoes wearing shoes my
whole [ __ ] life I'm not you know I'm
black but I'm not from Africa yes so I'm
not down man I'm not dear I've read the
science behind it oh yeah of like using
all the muscles oh yeah yeah I really
science behind it I also read sounds
[ __ ] have broken feet alright
that dude but minimalist shoes on trails
aren't bad yeah I'm not doing it no no
Matt will break my oh my god man no in
those things all the time really so you
like yeah it would kill me I'm gonna
tell you what I ran in fat tires
yesterday Under Armor fat tire which is
like a cushiony ass shoe you like it no
it was so easy it's like because
whatever no no Under Armour has these
fat tires it's basically like a BMX tire
track it's even made by a tire company
makes the tread yeah man it's like it's
got a mush to it and you you run on
these things man you could run over see
a thing about those five finger barefoot
shoes right I like running those but you
got to look where you're stepping you
can't step on any hard rocks
game over you'll [ __ ] up your foot yeah
quick cuz it's like it's gonna go right
in your foot Oh tiny little thin so I
went from those two vivos vivo barefoot
shoes that's what it looks like so when
you run on those [ __ ] that is a
cushiony glorious padding like when you
when you hit the ground it's like smushy
smushy smush I had the other ones Jamie
the ones with Ebola it's because it's
just like got that little click one that
you just put pull up yeah like those so
it's like you twist it with that that's
how you tighten it up with that little
boa adjuster thing it's like a got a
thread through it so you have to lace it
or anything like that you just slip them
on and pop that sucker down I like to
feel the ground a little bit my run yeah
you barely feeling [ __ ] with those yeah
but I like it
oh my joints didn't bother me at all
yesterday which is crazy like after a
good solid run cuz most of what I'm
running is hills right like pretty steep
and it's great my ass and legs never
been what do you weigh right now
200 yeah you thick dude man no so for me
the pounding of the you know the
constant pounds yeah the feet to the
ground it is uh it's it's rough on the
ankles it's rough on you know the the
joints but I don't feel it at all with
those fat tires it was mushy like I I
got done running I fell I got cheated so
much easier the cloud shoes yeah that's
just real cushioning and Cam's always
said that he runs with those a lot does
he yeah he's run with a bunch of those
like he's like cuz he runs so many
[ __ ] miles he was running a marathon
a day like pretty much every day I did
that for a while
bad bad bad oh my god got it I got wired
and doing that [ __ ] man what is this
right here so this is this is when I ran
I ran a hundred and fifty mile trail
race so the year before I did the same
race this 150 mile trail race I did it
in I think around 40 hours and I had to
walk the last 60 miles got pneumonia
here we go yeah a lot and then I told
the race director head [ __ ] I'm
coming back here next year and I'm
breaking the course record I went back
and did like 32 hours same race Wow now
know when you 33 hours so when you're
running what what shoes do you use right
now I'm wearing Brooks and also wear a
six so just
you know what kind of train I'm in where
I'm at stuff like for trails we were
what run for trails I actually for a
long time I wore a street running shoe
really for trails yeah for the longest
time how come because first of all my
body was so messed up the only shoe I
could ever wear with this Brooks
addiction it had even given Brooks
credit right now because back in the day
they would help a brother out I was
running so many miles yeah so Brooks I'm
not trying I'm not promoting Brooks
right now yeah Merry Christmas on them I
calling up the many times hey man can I
get like a discount or some [ __ ] hang up
not nobody nothing so but they do have a
good shoe and I and I and it was not
good PR horrible PR man you know I'm
saying like you know so but um yeah I
love their shoe belongs checking where
was that Brooks addiction can my my
biomechanics was so messed up I tried so
many different shoes and and that was a
so I can now wear a neutral shoe so how
I used to run and very few people know
this I used to have heel wedges inserts
heel wedges and get compression tape
because my body was pushed so far in
from being so tight in my hip flexors
that so how I got such bad stress
fractures was my bottle mechanic so
there's a picture my toe in there cuz my
my toes just jammed in front of my shoes
cuz my whole body's got just like bent
in so you when you're saying bent in for
people just listed in your if your hands
are flat on a table you're turning the
outside of your hands in up so that your
thumbs are going down those are my two
big toes right going down we're going
down and into the shoe and the outside
of your foot was up was above it right
so what I had to do to run because I was
like God I got stress fractures all the
time and my feet were so [ __ ] up
sometimes you see that with people's
shoes like how they're worn out warning
horn out on the side ways exactly like a
wedge rock and we look at it from behind
it crazy yeah that was my shoe so I had
to get a heel wedge to keep my heel from
going down guys severe tendinitis in the
back of medical that's how you had to
make it thicker on one size right stuff
for on the inside flat right so the
inside I had to push up and I to get
compression tape
it was compression tape heel wedges and
an insert and that's how I ran every
[ __ ] day did you go to a running
coach or anything don't know but did you
want to know what you were doing wrong
you know what man that was part of that
garanimal mindset man
[ __ ] it me I'm supposed to be broken you
know but then I got smarter as time went
and said oh man this is some painful
[ __ ] running a hundred mile races with
this kind of tendinitis and my feet
being [ __ ] that it was so painful so I
was like you know what so then I started
stretching I was like my god all this
was from having a tight I got so mad
sick my god I was I was in all these
different contraptions and now I just
wear normal running shoe Wow yeah so I
went from being contraption DUP man
like literally contraption up so it's
all just the stretching that opened up
the range of motion open yeah now when
people talk about range of motion they
don't understand how tight I was like no
one understands like when you repeatedly
do what I was doing to myself and you
were born with this dress I was born
under like I hate I can't paint a clear
is it's pretty clear in the book man my
life was bad the stress I endured on a
day I had two people and my body was
proof of literally what my life was
doing to me it literally was not at all
my muscles up because I was always under
this fighter flight you know my my dad
that made me so [ __ ] scared of [ __ ]
you know to unwind this [ __ ] man
was like it was it was it was a hard
task you know i it was a hard it was a
hard task man so it's a lot of a man
it's not just all the hard training oh
but it's also the mind the mind because
think about it man when you under stress
that hip flexor that that's so as muscle
wish to attach to your t12 that that's
the only muscle that attaches your lower
body to your upper body and that's the
muscle that's that's your
fight-or-flight whenever you get nervous
or scared of something like that that
motherfucker's was it was tighten up
unto me I'm your whole body is I lived
in that like almost fetal position in my
mind for so many years so I was always
under this like
tight neck tension [ __ ] guy but I've
walked around like I'm some cool here's
my new hairstyle
pants are sagging and I'm a cool dude
man right but that was not a costume I
had a costume war every day yeah got
tired of burning that [ __ ] man
next costume I want you to be in as a
jujitsu key with a white belt dog I
always send your picture man no fiction
no you gotta cuz I already played this
bass it around you know it is I'm gonna
set it up Nashville I know there's some
places out there Nashville
holler at me trust me yeah I'm sure they
will
we'll find you a spot of fine spot
listen man this book is [ __ ]
fantastic I'm halfway in I can't wait to
finish it and just thank you thank you
for the inspiration thank you for being
so honest experiencing yourself
I appreciate the [ __ ] appreciate you
brother thanks again thank you
bye everybody thanks a lot
[Music]